la séance est ouverte
mes chers collègues notre ordre du jour
appelle l'audition de Monsieur Patrick
pouillané président directeur général de
Total énergie je vous remercie monsieur
le Président de de venir ici répondre
aux questions des parlementaires et les
éclairer de vos connaissances et de vos
analyses sur un dossier connaissance
analyse que vous êtes plus qu'aucun
autre vous êtes même le sol à pouvoir
délivrer avec ce degré d'acuité cette
audition aurait dû se tenir le 21
septembre dernier nous en étions
convenus avec le président puyanné mais
nos collègues de la commission spéciale
qui souhaitait l'entendre le même jour
[Musique]
nous sommes demandés de surseoir à
l'audition du président puyané de
manière à le recevoir donc vous êtes
venus chez nos collègues j'ai lu
d'ailleurs le compte rendu de cette de
cette audition qui était très
intéressante alors je crois qu'il est
inutile de vous présenter longuement
vous êtes très connu je rappellerai
quand même ce que certains d'entre vous
doivent bien savoir c'est que monsieur
pouyanet est d'abord un grand serviteur
de l'État puisque diplômé de l'École
Polytechnique et de l'École des Mines
il a servi
à Matignon sous le gouvernement de
Monsieur Balladur il a été après il a
été collaborateur de au cabinet du
ministre à la poste autolux au
télécommunications et à l'espace
jusqu'en 97 ensuite il est entré et
c'est à ce titre là que nous l'invitons
aujourd'hui il est entré dans le groupe
Elf
groupe d'État originellement qui a été
absorbé en 2000 dans des conditions
chacun se rappelle par le groupe Total
et monsieur pouyanet est devenu dans des
conditions particulièrement dramatiques
directeur général de Total en 2014 à la
suite du décès accidentel sur à
l'aéroport de Moscou de Monsieur
Christophe de Marjorie dont le souvenir
est très présent pas seulement par ses
attributs
capillaires ou mais également par sa
truc son énergie et ses qualités de
communication je crois que nous pensons
toujours quel que soit
l'appréciation que nous pouvons porter
sur le rôle du chef d'entreprise nous
avons pour Monsieur de Marjorie un
souvenir très ému vous êtes après devenu
d'abord directeur général puis PDG du
groupe depuis 2015 c'est donc vous êtes
le contraire d'un parachuté s'il y a
quelqu'un qui a vraiment fait ses
classes dans ce groupe qui en connaît
tout et je crois que c'est très très
précieux pour nous de vous accueillir
aujourd'hui donc c'est avec c'est avec
un beaucoup de plaisir et d'intérêt que
je vous salue et je sais que il y a eu
pas mal de polémiques autour de
différents aspects de votre action je
crois que c'est polémique doivent donner
lieu à des débats peut-être mais
certainement pas à des mises en cause
personnelle et je pense je compte sur la
la le civisme et la courtoisie de tous
mes collègues pour que cette audition se
passe dans de très bonnes conditions
alors je
un titre d'introduction je dirais que
personnellement je crois que nous
interrogeons trois personnes aujourd'hui
d'abord nous interrogeons le citoyen
pouyané comme je l'ai rappelé vous êtes
un serviteur de l'État vous êtes d'abord
un citoyen et un citoyen
particulièrement éclairé sur les
questions énergétiques nous sommes
confrontés je crois tout le monde ici en
est conscient
à un défi qui est le défi de la
transition la transition énergétique et
du et la transition climatique qui est
peut-être le défi le plus important
auquel nous sommes confrontés à échéance
d'une quarantaine d'années et vous êtes
sur ce point compte tenu de vos
fonctions compte tenues de votre
expérience particulièrement éclairée
alors nous interrogerons tous sur la
signification exacte de ce qu'on doit
faire et je pense que ça serait
intéressant de notre part pour nous de
bénéficier de vos lumières pour nous
éclairer en particulier sur les trois
défis qui sont
ceux que nous que nous vivons qui sont
un défi de la prévisibilité nous ne
savons pas du tout ce que demain de quoi
demain sera fait en matière de mix
énergétique nous sommes un peu dans la
et nous sommes confrontés à un risque
important qui est je crois le syndrome
du Minitel c'est à dire est-ce que nous
faisons confiance à des technologies qui
sont celles dont nous disposons
aujourd'hui alors même que peut-être
elles seront dépassées demain et si
elles sont dépassées demain on aura
effectivement le regret d'avoir fait de
mauvais choix donc là j'aimerais bien
vous que nous vous éclairiez sur la
façon dont vous percevez l'avenir de la
situation énergétique deuxièmement les
limites de exemplarité nous sommes alors
là c'est un autre syndrome c'est pas le
syndrome du du
que je que je viens d'évoquer du Minitel
c'est le syndrome de la clé et du
réverbère l'homme qui cherche la clé qui
l'a perdu sous le réverbère non pas
parce qu'elle s'y trouve mais parce
qu'il y a de la lumière ce serait
verbère transposer à notre situation
nous agissons très fortement à
l'intérieur de nos frontières nous
sollicitons effectivement des efforts de
la mobilisation de chacun d'entre nous
alors même que l'enjeu dont il est
question est un enjeu universel
géopolitique passant d'abord par la
conversion à des exigences de transition
de grands acteurs sur lequel nous pesons
relativement peu comme la Chine l'Inde
les États-Unis pour ne citer que or
cette ce défi de l'exemplarité
nous pose problème parce que
que vous en faisons trop unilatéralement
nous pouvons nous affaiblir
économiquement sans avoir un résultat
aussi considérable que celui que nous
attendons j'aimerais bien notamment que
vous nous écailler sur certains aspects
de cette affaire le troisième défi qui
est très compliqué c'est le défi de
l'adaptabilité en quoi sommes-nous
capables de faire les changements
nécessaires sans mettre en cause notre
compétitivité économique sans mettre en
cause nos équilibres sociaux sans mettre
en cause même nos équilibres politiques
notamment le degré de contrainte que
nous envisageons d'imposer à nos
concitoyens dans quelle mesure il est
compatible avec le maintien d'une
société libre ce sont des échéances très
précises alors sur concrètement je crois
que c'est ces questions pourraient se
centrer autour notamment de la question
de la voiture j'aimerais bien que vous
nous éclairiez sur la façon dont vous
percevez monsieur breton a émis des
propos assez dis par rapport à ce que
nous entendions jusqu'à présent comment
voyez-vous la perspective ou qui
fournissez en fait du carburant à
l'ensemble des voitures européennes et
même mondiales comment voyez-vous la
portée réelle de l'interdiction du du
moteur thermique à échéance relativement
brève considérez-vous que ce défi est
relevable considérez-vous que il peut
être relevé dans des conditions qui
soient véritablement source de des
économies d'énergie
fossiles que nous espérons et comment
peut-il être assumé sans avoir des
risques collatéraux trop importants sur
la compétitivité économique de l'Europe
je pense qu'il y a un point de focus sur
lequel nous serions effectivement
intéressé à vous entendre le deuxième le
deuxième
Patrick puyannet que je voudrais
interroger c'est l'acteur géopolitique
vous êtes vous êtes à la tête d'une
entreprise vaste entreprise puissante
riche entreprenante qui a eu des
relations très étroites avec notamment
et je rappelais le souvenir de
Christophe de Marjorie avec la Russie
vous avez vous vous êtes vous vous
désengagez dans des conditions
difficiles économiquesment humainement
difficiles de la Russie ça pose des
problèmes et au-delà de ça comment
percevez-vous en tant que que grand
spécialistes et grands acteurs sur le
marché de l'énergie comment
percevez-vous les conséquences de la
guerre du crâne est-ce que nous sommes
confrontés à une perturbation à très
long terme est-ce que nous sommes
confrontés à une situation qui va
arrêter nette le ou partiellement
la substitution d'énergie
le remplacement d'énergie fossile par
des énergies renouvelables est-ce que
vous considérez que
les coûts de l'énergie qui vont
principalement les Européens vont être
un problème numéro un fondamental pour
les économies européennes et le
troisième citoyen pouillonné que je
voudrais interrogé c'est évidemment le
chef d'entreprise vous êtes à la tête
d'une entreprise immense d'une
entreprise multinationale qui pose de
problème le premier problème c'est celui
du contrôle je crois qu'il faudrait
quand même se dire nous autres
politiques que si on a un problème pour
contrôler multinationales c'est parce
que nous n'avons pas bâti les outils
multinationaux a commencé par l'outil
européen où les outils multinationaux
capables d'encadrer la politiquement
l'activité de groupe qui effectivement
interviennent sur toutes les latitudes
mais au-delà de ça il y a le problème
qui est posé de des bénéfices vous êtes
une entreprise qui fait d'importants
bénéfices ce qui pose un problème
intéressant sur le plan théorique est-ce
qu'il est bon ou est-ce qu'il est
mauvais qu'une entreprise en charge
responsabilité énergétique importante
face de des bénéfices est-ce qu'on
considère que ces immoral ou est-ce
qu'on considère que ce n'est pas la
condition nécessaire pour créer des
investissements qui sont effectivement
la clé de la transition énergétique à
terme c'est un problème d'utilisation de
la valeur ajoutée et là vous voyez les
critiques qui sont adressées à votre
groupe vous expliquer que
votre vous allez faire pour 40% à terme
d'énergie
renouvelable et en réalité vous devra
acteurs considèrent que l'essentiel de
votre activité ça reste les énergies
fossiles le gaz le pétrole et que la
part du renouvelable et très limitée
alors sur toutes ces questions il y a
des interrogations immenses et nous
avons conscience en vous recevant
monsieur le Président d'avoir affaire à
quelqu'un qui est capable l'un des rares
l'une des rares personnalités en France
qui soit capable d'apporter des éléments
d'information des éléments d'analyse de
première de qualité vous avez la parole
merci de m'accueillir aujourd'hui bon je
sais pas si en 10 ou 15 minutes je vais
réussir à répondre à tout ce que vous
avez posé comme question je vais essayer
de brosser rapidement le tableau bon
d'abord la transition l'énergie
l'énergie est un bien essentiel à tout
développement économique social
qui doit avoir trois caractéristiques
d'une politique énergétique la première
c'est qu'ils font vise une énergie
fiable sur
ça paraît évident ici même si en ce
moment il y a d'ailleurs des débats même
en Europe c'est pas évident pour un
milliard de personnes sur la planète qui
n'ont pas accès à l'énergie
la deuxième caractéristique c'est que va
être durable j'aurais pu le mettre en
produit durable c'est à dire au sens
climatique du terme puisqu'on a un
impératif qui a été auquel total énergie
souscrit qui a été signé dans l'accord
de Paris on doit faire face aux
changements climatique au dérèglement
climatique et l'énergie notamment
l'énergie fossile et source d'émissions
de carbone qui peuvent ces questions là
donc les durabilité et la deuxième
impératif le troisième caractéristique
que l'on vit mais façon mèche de façon
en 2022 c'est son caractère abordable et
je dirais après 25 ans dans l'énergie on
voit bien que c'est le prix de l'énergie
qui pilote à peu près toutes nos
politiques parce que c'est un bien
essentiel que les gens en ont besoin et
que lorsqu'on commence on a un salaire
mais la première chose qu'on doit faire
c'est se chauffer bouger pour pouvoir
vivre et c'est vrai dans également pour
toute le développement économique et
social de piller émergents donc le
caractère abordable et l'homme cherche
depuis des siècles
d'énergie la plus abordable possible et
vie des révolutions énergétiques
successives
avant c'est le charbon puis on a trouvé
le pétrole trouver de gaz le nucléaire
etc il est clair que l'énergie la plus
dense la plus abordable qu'on ait trouvé
c'est le pétrole et tout le défi de la
transition énergétique qui est en fait
est posée aujourd'hui c'est comme on
fait pour passer d'un système mondial
qui je vous le rappelle est à 81% fourni
par des énergies fossiles en gros 30% de
charbon 30% de pétrole 20% gaz c'est
juste des ordres de grandeur
vers un système sans ces énergies
fossiles à l'échelle de la planète pas
qu'à l'échelle d'un pays puisque le
changement climatique est un défi global
et que bien sûr que nous devons faire
des efforts parce que nous avons une
responsabilité historique dans nos pays
développés mais que il ne servait à rien
à les faire tout seul si le reste de la
planète ne nous suit pas
le défi est Prométhée et pourquoi je dis
ça quand je suis rentré dans l'énergie
il y a 25 ans la part des énergies
fossiles c'est 82%
. cette année l'année dernière c'était
81 % alors il s'est passé des choses
entre temps mais ce qui s'est d'abord
passé c'est que la population de la
planète augmente et que donc tous les
efforts importants que nous faisons même
s'ils sont insuffisants pour construire
des énergies de décarbonées
et bien en fait sont absorbés par la
demande supplémentaire
liée à la croissance de la population et
ça c'est un sujet très important et
majeur bien comprendre parce que pour
moi le défi de la transition énergétique
c'est comment on fait pour répondre à
une population croissante tout en même
temps des carbonant une population
croissante qui toutes aspire
légitimement au niveau de la planète à
avoir accès à de l'énergie et le sujet
n'est pas tant d'ailleurs dans nos pays
développés occidentaux que dans les pays
asiatiques sud-américains africains où
il y a une demande d'énergie d'une
énergie pas chère et on le voit de façon
spectaculaire cette année où les prix du
gaz s'envolant sous la pression
européenne les pays asiatiques
reviennent vers le charbon et donc il y
a aujourd'hui un passage je vais revenir
là-dessus du gaz vers le charbon parce
que le charbon encore une fois et
l'énergie la moins chère pour faire
d'électricité dans des pays qui en ont
besoin donc le défi il est là et il
n'est pas simple à régler et
comment et il est collectif il pose bien
évidemment beaucoup de
beaucoup de questions y compris dans le
fait que on peut d'ailleurs s'interroger
enfin moi je m'interroge pour savoir si
l'efficacité des milliards que nous
allons investir dans notre propre
transition énergétique sont le plus
efficace à chercher à abattre les les
émissions marginales de CO2 entre
marginal même si elles existent encore
une fois dans nos pays alors pendant ce
temps-là il faudrait des milliards voire
des trilliards pour arriver à maîtriser
la croissance des émissions de carbone
de deux pays majeurs que sont la Chine
et l'un notamment l'Inde qui n'a un mix
énergétique domestique fondamentalement
de charbon et de renouvelables mais un
mix charbon renouvelable n'est pas
nécessairement bon pour le pour le
climat
tout ça tout ça est un système complexe
et je sais bien que je vais choquer
certains mais croire qu'on peut faire
cela
en une nuit n'est juste pas possible
la transition le mot transition prendra
du temps je sais bien que on va me dire
les experts du climat de disent qu'il y
a urgence oui mais en même temps tout le
monde nous voulons vivre et notre
capacité à accepter de changer nos
comportements nos vies n'est pas notre
société n'est pas aussi claire que cela
regardez ce qui se passe cette année les
prix de l'énergie augmentent à cause de
la guerre des effets et les États les
États européens doivent mettre en place
des systèmes de subvention aux énergies
d'aujourd'hui et l'énergie d'aujourd'hui
elle est fossile
donc il y a là un défi qui est important
et ce que je crois c'est que pour
réussir cette transition énergétique
aujourd'hui on va puisque je suis un
producteur d'énergie on va beaucoup
parler d'offres on a le sentiment que si
on baisse la production d'énergie
fossile on va régler le problème mais le
problème c'est que la demande d'énergie
fossile la demande d'énergie tout court
qui aujourd'hui est majoritairement
fourni par les elle ne baisse pas la
demande d'énergie continue à croître
et tant qu'elle croit si nous
producteurs d'énergie fossile bah nous
décidons comme on l'a fait d'ailleurs je
vais revenir là-dessus au total énergie
de réduire nos investissements et bien à
la fin ce qui est l'adaptation entre la
demande et l'offre c'est les prix qu'ils
font et d'ailleurs c'est spectaculaires
c'est ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce qui
se passe exactement en ce moment nous
avons réduit à l'échelle de la planète
les investissements dans les énergies
fossiles de 700 milliards en 2014 à 400
milliards cette année je parle pas pour
Total énergie nous c'est 20 milliards en
gros à 12 milliards
on a réduit de 40%. or il y a quelque
chose qui est que il faut comprendre
c'est que si nous n'investissons pas il
y a un déclin naturel des champs de
pétrole et de gaz de l'ordre de 4 à 5 %
par an c'est pas une usine de
médicaments le pétrole la fournisseur il
y a un déclin étoile pourquoi parce que
au fur et à mesure qu'on produit un
puits la pression dans le puits diminue
et l'année suivante on perd de la
production donc ce phénomène là il est
majeur parce que ça veut dire que
lorsqu'on dit pour Total énergie par
exemple comme je vais perdre 4% par an
on mange déciderai d'investir dans
l'énergie fossile en 15 ans je vais
perdre 60% de ma production
la question c'est quand est-ce qu'on
décide d'arrêter pour arriver à
rejoindre le point de 2050 que l'on vise
et donc si on a et donc il faut qu'on
continue à investir pourquoi parce que
pendant ce temps là pour l'instant nous
continuons effectivement en prenant la
voiture à utiliser des véhicules
thermiques et que l'on voit que quand
malheureusement pour 10 ans d'autres
raisons on n'arrive pas à fournir
l'essence auprès de nos concitoyens ça
se passe pas bien donc il faut
le défi il est donc pour moi il est
double il faut que bien sûr nous devons
massivement investir pour construire le
système décarboné ce que j'appelle le
système B l'énergie de demain et
aujourd'hui c'est 700 milliards de
dollars qui sont alloués à investir en
gros dans cette énergie décarbonée donc
plus que dans les énergies fossiles en
fait le vrai chiffre qu'il faudrait être
capable de passer 700 milliards il
faudrait passer à 1,5 trilliards de
dollars par an
si on veut être dans la trajectoire donc
il faut doubler à l'échelle de la
planète et il faut doubler notamment
dans la partie énergie renouvelable mais
aussi dans la partie électricité et
l'électricité il ne faut pas l'oublier
les réseaux d'électricité parce que plus
on produira d'énergie renouvelable
décentralisée plus il faudra des réseaux
aujourd'hui on les oublie un peu mais
les réseaux sur lequel nous vivons y
compris en Europe aux États-Unis ils
datent en gros de après la guerre les
investissements sont relativement
limités donc il y a il y a un effort
gigantesque à faire mais pour l'instant
ce système B il n'existe que de façon
embryonnaire il ne peut couvrir que 5
7%, ils ont 10% des besoins mondiaux
donc notre défi est bien sûr de
construire massivement le système B mais
si on arrête d'investir dans le système
de l'énergie d'aujourd'hui qui nous fait
vivre et qu'on fait on fait diminuer
cette énergie et bien ça ne fonctionnera
pas la transition ne peut pas
fonctionner donc nous devons trouver le
bon la bonne
la transition la bonne balance entre
guillemets le bon équilibre pardon en
français entre investir dans l'énergie
de demain et accélérer et en même temps
et c'est un impératif et en même temps
maintenir le système énergétique
d'aujourd'hui tant que nous n'avons pas
suffisamment construit le système B ça
c'est ça l'équation et ça ça ne va pas
se faire en un an en deux ans ça va
prendre un système énergétique ça se
construit en décennies
tout à l'énergie pour venir sur nous et
après je reviendrai sur la partie
géopolitique applique exactement cela le
choix stratégique que nous avons fait en
2020 et Total est devenu total énergie
et c'est pas simplement pour changer de
nom c'est parce que ça traduit un vrai
changement d'énergie c'est que nous
avons décidé que lorsqu'on regarde les
marchés de l'énergie on voit bien que le
marché pétrolier qui est sur lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui va stagner voire et
puis diminuer on voit que le marché
gazier peut lui croître pour l'instant
mais il va aussi diminuer or l'énergie
de transition c'est l'électricité il
faut électrifier l'économie et pour
électrifier l'économie il faut franchir
il faut construire un système électrique
à base énergies renouvelable à base
également de centrales à gaz pour
assurer des moyens de fédération
flexibles à base de batterie et de
moyens de stockage de l'électricité qui
n'est pas le sujet le plus simple et
donc nous avons décidé d'ajouter pour ça
que Total et de devenir total énergie un
nouveau métier qui est l'électricité
dans lequel nous investissons une
investissons pas de façon sont limités
puisque en 2022 sur les 16 milliards
d'investissements 4 milliards 4
milliards 25% de nos investissements
sont consacrés aux énergies décarbonées
et notamment à bâtir ce pilier
d'électricité nous aurons à la fin de
cette année 16 Go 16 GW donc c'est à peu
près l'équivalent de capacités d'énergie
renouvelable ou centrale à gaz
l'essentiel synergie renouvelable
l'année prochaine la fin des prochaines
ça sera plus de 22 gigawatts l'objectif
étant d'atteindre 35 gigawatts en 2025
et 100 à la fin de la décennie ensuite
une évolution majeure pour nous alors
oui nous continuons à investir 12
milliards dans les énergies fossiles
quand je regarde ce qui commence à
fonctionne c'est à peu près 6 7
milliards pour juste maintenir notre
activité actuelle parce que il faut
maintenir et ces quatre à cinq milliards
dans des nouveaux projets et notamment
dans des projets de gaz naturel liquéfié
ça me permet d'aller vers le deuxième
sujet qui est la question de la
géopolitique bon d'abord ce que nous
vivons juste un point la Russie vous le
savez c'est un sujet majeur dans le
monde de l'énergie c'est le troisième
producteur mondial de pétrole le
deuxième exportateur
c'est le deuxième producteur de gaz
naturel le premier exportateur c'est le
sixième producteur de charbon le
troisième exportateur il est aussi
d'ailleurs au passage 4e producteur de
nickel et 6e de cuivre c'est plutôt pour
les énergies renouvelables c'est donc la
disruption russe est un sujet majeur
dans le monde de l'énergie
qui a des conséquences notamment pour
nous Européens côté pétrole je dirais
d'ailleurs nous total énergie très vite
on a dit qu'on pourrait s'en passer et
on va s'en passer les impacts sont on
pourra revenir dans des questions sur
ces questions sont je dirais
relativement limité côté gaz par contre
pour nous européens c'est majeur alors
je voudrais jusque pourquoi c'est majeur
et qu'est-ce qui se passe sur le gaz
lorsqu'on coupe le gaz russe et en fait
la vérité c'est qu'on a construit le
système européen depuis maintenant 20
ans comme si le gaz russe était un gaz
domestique il ne l'est pas nous le
découvrons mais c'est comme ça qu'on a
construit le marché gazier européen et
qu'on a construit entre guillemets notre
indépendance
si on peut dire le mot étant plutôt une
dépendance
représente à lui tout seul tout le gaz
russe c'est 100 millions de tonnes de
gaz naturel liquéfié 100 millions de
tonnes la production mondiale de gaz
naturel liquéfié c'est 400 millions de
tonnes ça veut dire quoi que l'Europe et
cette année on n'a pas pris 100 millions
de tonnes on est allé chercher 40
millions de tonnes sur le marché mondial
du gaz naturel on a fait un choc de
demande de 10% du marché sur le marché
mondial du gaz naturel qui est fier
c'est énorme dans le marché un marché
énergétique c'est 10% pour les amener en
Europe on a dû les prendre en Asie
contre les Chinois les Japonais les
Coréens qui ont été destinataires et
comme on l'a fait en faisant monter les
prix
parce que le marché du gaz naturel une
usine gaz sexualité ces investissements
de d'une dizaine de milliards ça se
construit pas parce que je le décide
pour 5-6 ans et donc c'est 400 millions
de tonnes l'année dernière c'est 2380
millions de tonnes exactement ils vont
pas bouger rapidement la prochaine vague
de construction puisqu'il y a des villes
qui se construisent sachant que le covid
avait à peu près arrêté les
investissements arrivent en 26 27 donc
on a un système contre un par l'offre
400 millions de tonnes et nous Européens
cette année on a demandé 40 et
potentiellement si on doit remplacer
tout le gaz russe c'est 100 millions de
tonnes donc ce choc il est majeur et
c'est pour ça que les prix du gaz se
sont envolés nous avons une nouvelle
dépendance bon le gaz naturel liquéfié
pourquoi nous nous étions pas avant
parce qu'il est plus cher que le gaz
russe
la vérité c'est qu'on avait dépendance
au gaz russe qui était aussi une
dépendance
je dirais parce que le gazou c'est ce
qu'on fait de moins cher
et donc on a un des facteurs
compétitivité de l'industrie européenne
notamment de nos voisins d'autres reins
c'était le gasus lorsque nous remplaçons
ce gaz russe par du gaz naturel
liquéfier qui vont en gros deux fois
plus cher et ben oui nous Européens on a
un problème de compétitivité sur
l'énergie il y a un pays d'ailleurs qui
connaît cette situation depuis 30 ans il
s'appelle le Japon le Japon est un pays
qui vit avec une énergie beaucoup plus
chère que le reste de la planète parce
qu'il a d'ailleurs créé le gaz
naturels il importe à peu près tout son
énergie il y a du charbon mais il y a du
gaz naturel qui est fier il avait les
nucléaire mais il faut kushima l'a fait
lui a posé des questions et qu'est-ce
qu'a fait le Japon d'ailleurs au passage
ça c'est il a fermé ses frontières c'est
à dire qu'il a mis les tarifs douaniers
pour protéger son industrie
parce que quand vous retrouvez avec des
facteurs de compétitivité qui n'en sont
plus il faut prendre des décisions si on
veut protéger
son industrie ça c'est pas de la
compétence en tant que patron d'énergie
mais c'est juste un commentaire j'invite
beaucoup à regarder comment le Japon
réagit face pour mesurer son économie
face à une énergie chère
donc on a on a cette disruption l'autre
conséquence quand même majeure qui moi
m'a frappé je voulais le partager avec
vous commission des affaires étrangères
après le le début du conflit j'avais été
amené très vite à aller en Inde pour
dire cette raison puisqu'on investit en
Inde et j'avais été très frappé de la
réaction des interlocuteurs indiens puis
après je suis allé au Moyen-Orient qui
en gros alors que nous on vivait je
dirais dans ce drame et dans le stress
d'une agression russe sur l'Ukraine mais
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait vous
européen pour en arriver là
et je me suis rendu compte que l'image
la vision que nous avions de ce conflit
nous occidentaux nous Européens et avec
je dirais j'allais à nos alliés
américains le camp occidental n'était
pas du tout partagé par l'immense
majorité du reste du monde
qui nous regardent comme si on en est
correspondables on n'a pas fait ce qu'il
fallait et d'ailleurs on a vu et puis
par ailleurs très surpris de notre
attitude non européen de d'engager des
sanctions unilatérales et puis après
d'aller consulter les Nations unies pour
vérifier qu'on avait raison et ce
phénomène il est il est très important à
prendre en compte parce qu'il traduit
pour moi effectivement notre monde on
avait construit un monde global basé sur
je dirais le commerce en espérant que le
commerce
entraînerait je dirais nos idéaux
démocratiques après la chute du mur en
on est passé dans un monde qui
clairement et on l'avait vu avec le
covid mais on le revoit aujourd'hui
encore plus je trouve avec ce conflit
qui devient beaucoup plus géopolitique
au sens de cassure de bloc et on a un
bloc occidental mais nous sommes un
milliard de personnes en gros si je fais
en grosse masse le sud c'est plutôt 6
milliards de personnes il faut pas se
tromper dans l'analyse qu'on fait ce
n'est pas que les Chinois qui peuvent
plus ou moins soutenir les Russes je
pense qu'il y a beaucoup plus de monde
que ça dans le Sud qui nous regarde et
ça rejoint d'ailleurs au passage le
débat en ce moment qu'il y a à la COP 27
qui est un peu un débat de la même
nature géopolitique entre le nord enfin
l'Occident nous pays développés
et les pays du Sud qui disent et
notamment en ce moment les pays
africains mais nous aussi nous avons le
droit de nous développer ok il y a une
cassure qui est en train de s'opérer à
travers un centre de conflits de crise
et c'est à mon avis un sujet qu'il ne
faut faut pas sous-estimer le sud c'est
6 de personnes nous sommes un milliard
et il nous regarde de façon pas
nécessairement aussi ils sont il faut
comprendre que ces pilages vous connais
bien aussi les pays du Moyen-Orient ils
vivent leur futur par eux-mêmes
dorénavant et leur futur c'est l'Est
les pays du Moyen-Orient leur futur il
est à l'est c'est l'Asie d'ailleurs
c'est l'Asie qui achète leur pétrole
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup moins
l'Occident et donc vous avez aujourd'hui
des forces géopolitiques fortes entre
guillemets entre tous ces clubs de pays
et face à ça il faut bien les prendre en
compte dans les positions que nous
prenons nous-mêmes nous notamment
européens parce que l'Europe se retrouve
de point de vue énergétique et je
reviens au départ un peu comme le Japon
finalement alors les seules énergies
qu'il faut qu'on a c'est pour ça que je
pense que le plan européen est adéquat
il faut on a plus d'énergie fluide mais
nos énergies fossiles diminuent on
dépend des autres donc la solution c'est
effectivement d'accélérer pour aller
vers des énergies que nous maîtrisons
sur notre territoire ce sont les
énergies renouvelables je ne prononcerai
moins sur l'énergie nucléaire parce que
je ne suis pas l'expert vous inviterez
le présent de déesse si vous voulez
qu'il parle mais ce sont les énergies
qui sont je dirais de souveraineté dans
lesquelles on peut les maîtriser
intervalle ça va prendre du temps de
pouvoir construire un tel système
énergétique européen je dirais plus
souverain même si à la fin il y a
toujours des dépendances d'autres les
énergies renouvelables une des questions
majeures aujourd'hui c'est que la
plupart des composants sont fabriqués en
Chine donc on se retrouve dans une autre
dépendance et que de moins les matériaux
pour les batteries il faudra de toute
manière également les importer mais il
n'empêche qu'il y a il y a là un sujet
je dirais de sécurité énergétique qu'il
faut que que l'on repense bon je vais
sur total énergie écoutez total énergie
je viens d'écrire sa stratégie à
beaucoup évolué
elle a beaucoup évolué d'ailleurs j'ai
nous avons un défi aujourd'hui parce que
bon naturellement les prix des énergies
hydrocarbures sont plus élevées un
centre d'actionnaires nous disent mais
pourquoi vous n'investissez pas plus là
dedans on a décidé une stratégie on va
s'y tenir consistant à la fois à donc je
le répète à maintenir notre production
de pétrole ne plus la faire croître
et surtout par ailleurs adapté notre
système de raffinage et de et de réseau
au fait qu'il y aura et qui est très
européen qui aura une transition
énergétique d'abord en Europe
continuez à croître sur le gaz naturel
qui est fier nous sommes devenus le
deuxième acteur mondial 3e si je compte
le Qatar avec Shell
du gaz naturel liquéfier et ensuite
encore une fois atteindre notre ambition
d'être parmi les 5 plus grands
producteurs d'énergie renouvelables
d'ici 2030 avec une centaine de
gigawatts voilà voilà le programme pour
Total énergie alors comment nous
répartissons notre valeur ajoutée alors
la valeur ajoutée elle fluctue
effectivement cette année elle est
beaucoup plus élevée
nous investissons et une des
conséquences des bénéfices plus
importants c'est que nous avons décidé
de passer de 14 à 18 milliards
d'investissements nous avons augmenté
nos investissements et notamment nos
investissements dans les énergies dites
décarbonées puisque l'an dernier on
était à trois on passe à 4 et nous avons
annoncé que nous montrerions jusqu'à 6
donc en gros un tiers du portefeuille le
la partie je dirais hydrocarbure reste
en stable pour assurer encore notre
mission dont je que j'ai décrite par
ailleurs oui nous répartition notre
valeur ajoutée avec nos actionnaires et
puis avec nos salariés et enfin
également avec des consommateurs puisque
nous avions pris l'initiative dès le
mois de mars de l'ancien son opérations
pour soutenir les consommateurs français
bon voilà après je vais pas répondre sur
la notion de contrôle qui relève plus du
Parlement je peux vous dire que des
sociétés comme les nôtres ne faisons
face à de nos très nombreuses
réglementations auxquelles elles ne vont
obéir d'autant plus que nous avons nous
sommes à la fois coté en Europe en
France et à New York donc le nombre de
de réglementation que nous en face est
important
et en même temps une des autres règles
que nous suivons ces missions nous
respectons le droit de tous les pays
dans lequel nous sont nous sommes
implantés qui est qui est majeur je
pense que je vais pas être plus long sur
ce plan là je vais alors
la voiture bon la voiture est un exemple
de transition bon je pense que Carlos
Tavares ou
serait bloqué animés on serait plus à
même pour moi pour parler sur la partie
construction automobile moi ce que
j'observe c'est que bon un choix est
fait je suis jamais très favorable à ce
que un choix technologique soit fait par
un pouvoir je dirais voir politique
chouette technologique c'est un choix
qui va
le risque du militaire je vais bien aimé
votre paradigme qui est réel pour moi la
vraie décision à prendre c'est quelles
sont les émissions de carbone qu'on veut
ou qu'on ne veut pas pour rouler parce
que il y a bien sûr le véhicule
électrique qui est une option on peut
imaginer qu'il y ait des options
alternatives l'une d'entre elles étant
d'ailleurs ce qu'on appelle des fuel
synthétiques qui seraient fait à partir
de CO2 et d'hydrogène pour fabriquer un
liquide synthétique qui pourrait
paramétrer de réutiliser des moteurs
thermiques
on peut parler du véhicule à hydrogène
ou du véhicule à batterie électrique du
pardon du pardon le véhicule de l'avion
mais ils ont un rayon relativement
limité si on veut des avions qui soient
comme aujourd'hui qui permet de
traverser l'Atlantique il faudra un
liquide et si c'est pas du pétrole ça
sera d'abord ce qu'on appelle des
carburants aériens durables mais juste
ayant en tête que si on a fait un
exercice théorique on a pris toutes tout
ce qui existe comme déchets à l'échelle
de la planète où il y a des lipides du
gras et on s'est dit si on transforme et
tout ça uniquement en carburant aérien
durable on arriverait qu'à couvrir en
2050 la moitié des besoins des avions
donc il faut qu'on invente autre chose
ce sont sans doute des fiouls
synthétiques donc on aura besoin de
créer ce nouveau ce nouveau ce nouveau
carburant il pourrait être utile pour la
voiture alors après l'autre conséquence
de ce que vous avez dit sur les écrits
c'est qu'il faut maintenant s'assurer
bien sûr s'il est électrique que
l'électricité soit décarbonée parce que
sinon on n'a pas fait un très grand
progrès
si il est continué à être produit même
encore dans certains pays européens avec
du charbon donc effectivement une
urgence à accélérer sur la décarbonation
l'électricité parce que sinon
notre équation sera pas parfaite
et ça c'est quand même pas encore gagné
c'est pas gagné parce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire renforcer les réseaux
électriques ça veut dire c'est pas
simplement la partie bande de recharge
n'est pas la partie qui m'inquiète le
plus pour être honnête pareil la partie
assez facile à mettre en oeuvre pour
autant messieurs les parlementaires que
vous régliez le problème des
copropriétés pardon et mesdames
excusez-moi excusez-moi pardon Mesdames
et Messieurs les parlementaires des
copropriétés je me permets d'en profiter
pourquoi parce que véhicule écrit demain
il sera chargé comme l'iPhone à 40% à
son domicile à 40% au bureau et 20% dans
les stations et dans les rues la
question pour nous c'est une révolution
majeure pour nous réseau pour notre
réseau de station-service qu'est-ce
qu'on va en faire on va garder le réseau
bien évidemment sur les grands axes mais
le réseau de proximité n'aura
probablement très peu d'utilité alors on
va sans doute construire électrique on
en est en train de construire quatre
autour de Paris dans certaines grandes
villes qui sera certainement désignée à
des professionnels des taxis etc mais
les particuliers vont profondément
changer de comportement et donc il y a
une urgence à se préoccuper et là ça pue
dans le stade compétence de nous
distributeurs et notamment des
copropriétés qui sont un vrai sujet pour
la je suis éloigné donc le véhicule
électrique qui est un défi c'est un
choix un choix majeur l'autre défi c'est
d'éviter qu'il soit chinois je peux me
permettre là c'est plutôt à Carlos de
vous Tavares vous l'expliquer mais il
est clair qu'aujourd'hui la Chine fait
aussi le Grand Paris du véhicule
électrique va le produire moins cher et
la question sera de ça devait d'éviter
qu'on fasse sur le véhicule électrique
ce qu'on a fait sur les panneaux
solaires ou l'Europe sur les panneaux
solaires et l'Allemagne notamment à
lancer une politique extrêmement
proactive dans les années 2005-2010 et a
lancé l'énergie solaire à l'échelle de
la planète de façon un grand succès
simplement on n'a pas construit
l'industrie solaire qui allait avait le
panneau solaire est devenu chinoise à
90% et qu'est-ce qui se passe en ce
moment depuis l'année dernière
l'imprimante donc on se retrouve là
aussi face à un problème il faut une
autre on essaye d'ailleurs nous de
diversifier nos sources
d'approvisionnement de panneaux solaires
en allant chercher par exemple en Inde
et en promouvant d'autres d'autres
subventions
bon voilà un peu ce que je peux décrire
en introduction j'ai pas répondu à la
même façon votre vie tout question mais
pour essayer de planter le décor et puis
je viens sur je suis prêt à répondre à
vos questions vous avez tout à fait
éclairé la question votre votre
intervention était placé sous le signe
du regretté 100 paix qui avait publié
deux volumes l'un et rien n'est simple
et le second tout se complique
maintenant je vais laisser la parole au
groupe et d'abord pour le groupe
Renaissance à Monsieur Viber 3 minutes
vous êtes énormément à vouloir
intervenir donc je suis obligé de vous
sanctionner d'arrêter de net à 3 minutes
monsieur Viber allez-y utiliser vos
trois minutes si le président merci
monsieur le président directeur général
de Total énergie je vous remercie pour
votre présentation au sein de notre
assemblée au moment même où se tient la
cop27 à Sharm el shake en Egypte 7 ans
après la signature des accords de Paris
lors de la COP 21 et alors que nous
traversons une crise énergétique inédite
alimentée par une guerre aux portes de
l'Europe
votre entreprise totale énergie leader
mondial dans le secteur des énergies
ambitionne d'être un acteur majeur de la
transition énergétique pour atteindre
vous l'avez dit à l'horizon 2050 la
neutralité carbone sur l'ensemble de ses
activités mondiales
compagnie française nous ne pouvons
qu'encourager nos ferons économiques et
industriels à poursuivre leur croissance
qui infinie doit profiter à nos
concitoyens néanmoins les défis pour
atteindre cet objectif sont nombreux
contraints par un contexte mondial
politique économique ou encore
environnemental des plus incertains
tension accrue dans l'Indo Pacifique
trouble sécuritaire dans le sel monter
en puissance des régimes libéraux à
travers le monde ou encore accélération
de la fonte des glaces dans l'épaule ou
dans les massifs montagneux ainsi la
dimension mondiale de votre entreprise
présente dans plus de 130 pays et qui
produit des hydrocarbures dans 29
d'entre eux dont certains sont contestés
comme un Ouganda ou au large de
l'Afrique du Sud vous Souma de
nombreuses contingences et un
environnement Sécur international en
voie de dégradation
en effet la trajectoire à court terme de
la demande mondiale d'énergie connaît un
rebond de la consommation de charbon
dans un contexte de relatif reprise
économique poste covid en 2021
entraînant des perturbations du marché
en cela une dégageurs et de soutenir les
efforts supplémentaires nécessaires pour
des carboner l'énergie tout en
garantissant la sécurité énergétique et
des prix abordables pour les
consommateurs
les prix actuellement élevés de
l'énergie ont placé l'efficacité
énergétique en tête de nos priorités
l'examen prochain d'un projet de loi sur
les énergies renouvelables l'Assemblée
nationale devrait tenter d'y répondre en
effet la crise actuelle doit être
l'occasion d'accroître les mesures
d'économie et d'efficacité énergétique
qui doivent nous mener à atteindre les
objectifs de l'accord de Paris
ainsi les énergies renouvelables moteur
principal de la décarbonation du mix
électrique connaissent une pénétration
rapide d'autant plus que la
préoccupation vis-à-vis de la sécurité
énergétique devient majeur dans de
nombreux pays l'hydrogène le gaz naturel
amenéas vers dire au fil du temps les
carburants liquides durables basés sur
les if y fuel sont des leviers de
décarbonation prometteur mais ne devrait
pas être utilisé à grande échelle avant
2030 ainsi la transition exige une
augmentation des dépenses pour
construire un nouveau système
énergétique décarbonée la période
actuelle est ainsi décisive les
investissements dans les énergies back
carbone doivent doubler d'ici à 2030
tandis que des investissements dans de
nouveaux développements pétroliers
gaziers sont encore nécessaires au moins
jusqu'au milieu des années 2030 pour
atteindre ce cap les investissements
massifs dans la recherche de
développement sont nécessaires pour
développer les technologies qui
alimenteront ce nouveau système
énergétique plus que jamais les énergies
toutes les énergies sont au centre des
préoccupations ma question est la
suivante même si vous y avez répondu en
grande partie comment total énergie
envisage de réaliser ses objectifs en
matière de transition énergétique en
adéquation avec les ambitions de la
France je vous remercie alors que les
défis géopolitiques écologiques et même
éthiques ne s'accumuler sur votre
entreprise merci
François je vous remercie le
rassemblement la chaîne merci Monsieur
soyez meilleur que Monsieur vive
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues Monsieur le Directeur Général
bouillané madame la Présidente Le Pen ne
pouvant être présente en commission
aujourd'hui je me fais savoir à travers
une question qu'elle souhaitait vous
poser directement et que je souhaite
vous adresser alors Monsieur le PDG je
souhaite attirer votre attention sur les
ambitions énergétiques de la France qui
sont portés par le groupe Total énergie
dans les eaux du canal du Mozambique
alors votre entreprise est présente dans
la région du Cabot Delgado où le
programme Mozambique GNL s'avère
prometteur malgré la stabilité
sécuritaire de la zone néanmoins ce sont
des eaux du canal qui sont situées plus
au sud que ma question s'oriente en
effet le canal du Mozambique est une
voie maritime importante puisque chaque
année transite dans ses eaux au moins
30% du trafic pétrolier mondial et
depuis 2017 la France administre une
très grande partie de l'archipel des
îles épars à savoir il le repas bassada
India Juan de Nova ainsi que l'archipel
des glorieuses des bases militaires ils
sont d'ailleurs installés depuis 1970
pour affirmer notre souveraineté là-bas
la zone est riche en ressouriotiques
minières et plus particulièrement il est
donc évident que la France tourne son
regard mais plus encore son industrie
vers cette manne énergétique qui se
situe à proximité de nos territoires
ultramarins lorsqu'elle n'est pas
présente dans les eaux même de notre Zee
pour l'or les prospections sont déjà
réalisées consistent à faire des
recherches sismiques en 3D ou bien des
carottages et ce sont des types
d'exploration qui ont été menées aux
îles des arches Juan de Nova par exemple
en revanche la France elle n'a pas la
direction directe encore moins le
monopole de ces prospections puisque le
ministère chargé des accords sur les
mines à accorder deux blocs
d'exploration des aides sur l'île le
premier qui était en 2005 a été accordé
à une entreprise norvégienne et le
second en 2008 à une entreprise
américaine et
nigérienne également alors il est grand
temps d'exercer notre souveraineté sur
place en faisant du Florent de notre
industrie et de l'industrie et de
l'énergie française qui est le groupe
Total énergie le promoteur d'une
exploitation gazir de grande ampleur
dans le canal du Mozambique alors
monsieur le Président Directeur Général
ma question est vaste mais mais je s'il
vous plaît une réponse précise quels
sont les ambitions du groupe Total dans
les eaux du canal du Mozambique au
regard de ses capacités de production
alors on sait que le cours du pétrole
remonte actuellement donc peut-être que
c'est une opportunité pour pour Sephora
et de plus la loi met enfin à la
recherche ainsi que l'exploitation des
hydrocarmures qui a été porté par
Nicolas Hulot et qui a été voté je vous
le rappelle en juillet 2017 prévoit
l'interdiction de l'attribution de
nouveaux permis de recherche d'énergie
fossile alors qu'il s'agisse du gaz
pétrole ou charbon et interdit le
renouvellement des concessions en
jusqu'en 2040 alors ces textes est-il un
frein à l'intérêt de Total énergie c'est
la question que je souhaiterais vous
poser et il me reste encore 30 secondes
alors ma dernière question portera sur
les opportunités économiques des très
grandes envergures qui sont
malheureusement rares dans les outre-mer
les ressources Gasia dans les eaux du
canal du Mozambique représente un
intérêt qui est majeur pour le
département de Mayotte et qui pourrait
être très utile dans la conduite de
recherche d'exploration de même qu'elle
s'inscrivent dans un contexte d'une
crise énergétique sans précédent comme
vous le savez je vous remercie pour la
réponse à ces trois questions je vous
remercie monsieur
Monsieur François de cette rigueur
quasiment la cérémonienne pour la France
insoumise madame panot
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
pouyanet vous savez le seul avantage
avec les écho terroristes de la trompe
de Total énergie c'est qu'il nous donne
l'embarras du choix en matière de
question tant les comptes à rendre sont
nombreux aussi je pourrais vous
interroger monsieur pouillané sur vos
aventures néo-coloniales sur le
continent africain votre méga projet
gazier et à coop en Ouganda par exemple
dont on estime si on prend en compte le
transport le raffinage et la combustion
du pétrole pour les par les pays
consommateurs qu'il produirait
l'équivalent de 25 fois les émissions
annuelles de l'Ouganda et de la Tanzanie
réunie là-bas le cauchemar est nommé
total à coup d'accaparement de terre
entraînant la violation des droits de
près de 100000 personnes comme l'ont
condamné récemment nos collègues du
Parlement européen dans une résolution
où votre méga projet gazier en Afrique
du Sud qui pourrait émettre à lui seul
l'équivalent d'un peu moins d'un an de
la totalité des émissions du pays en
plus de menacer la biodiversité marine
la pêche locale est verrouillée la
transition énergétique du pays comme je
pourrais aussi m'attarder sur votre sens
pour le moins douteux voir immoral des
priorités à travers la persistance de
vos activités en Russie elles vous ont
valu une plainte pour complicité de
crimes de guerre suite à l'enquête
affirmant qu'un gisement de gaz
coexploité par Total énergie a permis de
ravitailler les avions de guerre russes
c'est bien une diplomatie parallèle que
vous déployez à l'aune de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles tout
comme je pourrais vous interroger sur
les émissions réelles de votre
multinationale quand une estimation de
Greenpeace trouve un résultat près de
quatre fois supérieur à celui que vous
communiquez c'est à dire 1,6 milliards
de tonnes d'équivalent CO2 en intégrant
vos émissions indirectes lorsque vous
affirmez avoir émis 455 millions de
tonnes sur l'année 2019 aussi je
pourrais également vous interroger sur
vos états d'âme vis-à-vis de vos
prédécesseurs qui savaient depuis 1971
le rôle de la combustion des énergies
fossiles dans le réchauffement
climatique ou encore sur votre rente de
situation monsieur pyriani vous ayant
permis de dégager dernièrement des
bénéfices nets Induc de 6,6 milliards
principalement sur la vente de gaz ou
encore sur vos méthodes malhonnêtes à
l'égard de vos salariés pour retourner
l'opinion contre leur juste combat pour
le partage de la valeur je pourrais
également vous demander tout simplement
monsieur pouyanet si vous vous portez
mieux car vous pariez c'est un peu
chagriné par les remarques concernant
votre augmentation de 52%, et si vos 6
millions d'euros annuels vous permettent
encore de joindre les deux bouts je
pourrais enfin vous questionner sur tout
cela mais aussi plus rien n'est mais une
chose m'interroge en particulier si le
GIEC nous indique qu'il faut
immédiatement cesser tout nouveau projet
d'exploitation d'énergie fossile de
manière à conserver nos conditions
d'existence et de survie sur terre si
ces investissements fossiles sont
incompatibles avec nos objectifs
climatiques si vous dites vous-même pour
suivre un objectif de neutralité carbone
en 2050 alors comment expliquer vous la
poursuite de vos bombes climatiques à
travers le monde d'aucun nous disent que
la trajectoire climatique actuelle de
Total énergie nous emmène vers un monde
à 4,5 degrés quel est votre projet pour
la multinationale si ce n'est qu'elles
poursuivre ses activités dans un désert
humain et écologique je vous remercie
vous avez effectivement consacré
beaucoup de temps à énumérer les
questions que vous ne posiez pas
mais maintenant pour les républicains
monsieur cette lingette
monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur le Président d'acteur
général pour y aller je n'évoquerai pas
ce matin les bénéfices record réalisés
par votre entreprise et qui ont été que
partiellement redistribué aux salariés
aux Français car nous pourrions en
parler toute la matinée je me
concentrerai plutôt sur votre stratégie
d'investissement nous sommes forcés par
l'effet la crise énergétique qui a paru
a été 2021 a fait exploser les prix
d'énergie en outre vous l'avez dit nous
sommes très dépendants du gaz russe qui
représente aujourd'hui 40% du marché
européen du gaz et qui joue une part
importante dans notre consommation vous
avez expliqué à plusieurs reprises que
sans le gaz russe l'économie européenne
entre ré immédiatement en récession mais
au-delà c'est total qui en est dépendant
c'est vous qui lisez les chiffres le
montrent puisque vous expliquer
régulièrement que la stratégie de totale
est basée en grande partie sur le gaz
russe et que Total ne peut pas se
retirer des contrats à terme de gaz sur
25 ans
le gaz russe permet générer plus de 10%
de votre résultat et le groupe total
investi en aussi près de 20 milliards
d'euros c'est donc la santé financière
de Total qui est en jeu et derrière cela
la pérennité de notre approvisionnement
énergétique de notre économie mais aussi
nos objectifs de transition énergétique
puisque vous comptez sur le gaz comme
énergie de transition pour financer le
mix énergétique ma question est la
suivante l'adage dit que diriger ses
prévoir et ne rien prévoir c'est courir
à sa perte monsieur le Président
Directeur Général dans l'hypothèse d'un
arrêt complet des livraisons de gaz
pourriez-vous nous détailler votre
stratégie d'autre part pensez-vous qu'il
est judicieux d'avoir investi tant
d'argent dans un seul pays dans pour au
niveau du gaz russe certes vous dites
que le gaz russe était la moins chère
solution l'approvisionnement mais
peut-on être dépendant à ce point d'un
seul pays et face au contexte politique
que prévoyez-vous pour redéfinir la
stratégie d'investissement totale enfin
maintenant l'investissement
environnemental de Total comment
pouvons-nous contribuer à réduire
l'empreinte carbone totale tout en ne
fragilisant pas nos positions vis-à-vis
de nos concurrents étrangers en effet
imposer des contraintes qui pèseraient
sur votre activité mais qui te ferait
gagner des parts de marché à des
entreprises russes chinoises ou
américaines ça n'a aucun sens nous
devons soutenir total qui est encore
vulnérables grandes entreprises
françaises mais comme la bien dit le
président bourlange total doit également
rendre des comptes merci donc pour votre
présence ce matin totale par son ampleur
et par son impact sur l'économie
française à un devoir particulier
vis-à-vis de notre pays merci beaucoup
je vous remercie monsieur le député je
ne résiste pas au plaisir de citer quand
même puisque vous avez dit gouverner
c'est prévoir la phrase de turgo qui
prévoit le présent c'est très difficile
de prévoir le présent monsieur ceginski
pour le groupe démocrate modem et
indépendant
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues monsieur le Président
Directeur Général en 2011 le groupe
Total fait l'acquisition de SunPower un
des leaders mondiaux dans la fabrication
de panneaux solaires en 2016 total des
bourses près de 1 milliard d'euros pour
réaliser l'acquisition du fabricant de
batterie de haute technologie et leader
mondiale du secteur Saft basé dans mon
département de la Gironde vous déclarez
alors Monsieur le PDG que le 21e siècle
sera électrique vous ajoutez également
il nous faut intégrer le défi du
changement climatique et l'évolution du
mix énergétique qui va en découler les
prévisions de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie montre que la part du pétrole
va baisser au profit du gaz et des
renouvelables le groupe Total dispose
donc depuis 2016 d'actifs industriels
stratégiques permettant à ce leader
Français qui dispose parieur de
ressources financières importantes de
devenir un leader mondial de la
production d'énergie verte
à la lumière de ces acquisitions je
m'interroge sur vos projets
internationaux dont la plupart semblent
impacter l'environnement vous déclarez
en 2020 que la diversification du mix
énergétique de Total énergie prendra du
temps ainsi vous continuez de financer
d'investir dans des projets en lien avec
des énergies fossiles environ 80% de vos
investissements entre 2026 et 2030
seront orientés vers la production de
gaz et de pétrole
ces objectifs des tonnent donc avec
l'ambition environnementale que vous
affichez en 2016 lors de l'acquisition
de soft et vous continuez d'afficher
dans votre communication y compris dans
vos documents institutionnels notamment
avec le changement de nom que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure de votre groupe de
Total à Total énergie la majorité des
projets que vous financez ont des
impacts réels sur nos ressources
en effet au début du mois de septembre
le palme européen a adopté une
résolution d'urgence dénonçant des
risques majeurs pour l'environnement
causés par le projet dont Total énergie
et l'investisseur principal en Ouganda
et en Tanzanie nous pourrons donc
déplorer que Total énergie n'accélère
pas sa transformation vers la production
d'énergie des carbonée et respectueuse
de notre planète
notre pays la France a la chance de
disposer d'un champion de l'énergie avec
dexcellents résultats financiers
détenant des actifs technologiques
majeurs permettant cette transition et
une présence terrestre globale qui
pourrait apporter sa pierre à l'édifice
du combat contre le réchauffement
climatique monsieur le PDG n'est-il pas
possible de faire corréler le potentiel
que détient notamment le continent
africain grâce à la qualité et la
quantité de sa ressource solaire avec
les actifs stratégiques dont dispose le
groupe Total énergie
quand comptez-vous alors que notre
planète est soumise à des alias et
changement climatiques forts réellement
investir dans des projets à l'étranger
visant la production d'énergie
renouvelable le groupe Total compte il
rehausser ses objectifs en ce sens et
faire en sorte qu'il y ait rapidement
plus d'investissement dans les
renouvelables que dans les énergies
fossiles par ailleurs vous accordez une
place importante à la communication sur
la Responsabilité Sociétale des
Entreprises la norme ISO 26000 standards
international définit le périmètre de la
RSE autour de cette thématique centrale
notamment les droits de l'homme les
relations et conditions de travail et
l'environnement contenu des éléments
présentés dans cette question vis-à-vis
je vous aligné rapidement vos pratiques
opérationnelles à votre stratégie RSE je
vous remercie c'est moi qui vous
remercie monsieur le député maintenant
pour les socialistes et apparentés la
parole est au président fort
en RDC qui lui pourrait dégager
similaire de tonnes de CO2 mais à l'un
David mon collègue tout à l'heure il
reviendra alors vous connaissez la
définition que Oscar Wilde donnait du
cynisme il disait un cynique c'est ce
quelqu'un qui connaît le prix de tout
mais la valeur de rien et donc moi je
voulais vous poser quelques questions
sur l'échelle du cynisme
à laquelle vous pouvez consentir vous
connaissez le prix du baril de Brent
mais à combien évaluez-vous la vie d'une
famille vous allez pour ce projet
icoop exproprier 100 000 familles en
Tanzanie le prix de l'expropriation
c'est en moyenne
1160 dollars est-ce que quelqu'un pense
ici qu'avec 1160 dollars on peut ensuite
faire vivre sa famille quand on sait
qu'en plus le prix des terrains augmente
au fur et à mesure que le projet se
développe
vous allez nous dire que vous allez
créer 80000 emplois 80 000 emplois c'est
essentiellement les employés à la
construction du pipeline mais combien il
y en aura-t-il quand le pipeline sera
véritablement exploité moi on me dit que
c'est 5000 et que ce sont des emplois
hautement qualifiés qui ne profiteront
pas aux gens que vous aurez exproprier
au démarrage deuxième question vous nous
dites que la transition à l'instant ne
se fera pas en une nuit personne ne le
dit en réalité mais si votre
communication se fait beaucoup sur les
EnR la réalité c'est que vous
investissements ils se font
essentiellement sur les énergies
fossiles en 2015 vous avez vous-même
fixé un une trajectoire pour le monde
qui n'est pas celle du GIEC mais d'une
trajectoire qui fixe l'objectif de 3 à 3
et demi degrés pour le monde est-ce que
vous êtes vous avez renoncé cette
trajectoire là est-ce que vous avez
depuis réfléchi ou est-ce que vous êtes
toujours sur une trajectoire que vous
conseilleriez à l'époque comme une
trajectoire pragmatique dernière
question et j'en finis par là
derrière l'armure derrière
comme disait Jospin il faut fondre
l'armure parfois vous avez quatre
enfants moi aussi et la question c'est
quel héritage voulons-nous leur laisser
est-ce que c'est un compte en banque
fourni la fierté d'avoir été une
catastrophe mondiale et réversible et
c'est à l'homme que je m'adresse je vous
remercie monsieur monsieur le Président
maintenant la parole est pour horizon et
apparenté au président marchand de Julie
merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur pouyan et bonjour
il y a un inconvénient à ne pas être le
premier à s'exprimer c'est qu'il y a des
questions qui ont déjà été posées je
suis ici
notamment sur les problématiques et les
questionnements légitimes créés par vos
projets en Tanzanie et en Ouganda qui
sont
communément qualifiés de bombes
climatiques mais il y a également le
côté humain qui pose des questions et
celui qui m'a précédé s'est chargé de le
faire vous avez répondu d'ailleurs sur
ce sujet que ces projets doivent se
faire quoi qu'il arrive parce que vous
préférez que Total s'en charge plutôt
qu'une entreprise chinoise qui serait
sans doute moins regardante sur le
respect des droits de l'homme ou de la
biodiversité j'aimerais bien que vous
précisiez cette pensée
en 2022 votre entreprise a publié un
rapport sur son action pour le climat et
développement durable vous y ambitionnez
d'accompagner des changements décidés au
niveau européen pour rendre votre
entreprise neutre en carbone d'ici 2050
des leviers de cette action c'est la
compensation carbone des émissions
marginales de vos exploitations
d'hydrocarbures qui ne seront ni
recyclées ni capturés des initiatives
ont déjà été lancées sur ce plan vous
avez par exemple signé un engagement
avec la Fondation Good Planet en ce sens
afin de fabriquer des biodigesteurs en
Inde or de telles mécanismes de
compensation sont parfois considérés
comme relevant excusez-moi pour
l'anglicisme de greenwashing souvent
parce que le contrôle des initiatives de
revorestation et de protection des
milieux naturels est perçu comme
insuffisant si votre activité
d'exploitation d'hydrocarbures perdure
au même rythme de nombreux projets
similaires devront rapidement se
concrétiser dès lors et cette question
est un peu similaire à ceux qui m'ont
précédé comment total énergie
compte-elle assurer l'efficacité et la
durabilité des projets de compensation
carbone qu'elle financera à travers le
monde une autre question que je souhaite
vous poser mais qui est plus local les
répercussions des tensions mondiales sur
le marché de l'énergie amplifié dans
certaines territoires français des
problématiques je pense naturellement
aux outre-mer mais aussi à la Corse du
fait de son insularité
aujourd'hui ces tensions se font
vivement ressentir au sein de la filière
des grossistes et détaillants en
carburant et se malgré l'application
d'un taux de TVA réduit cette situation
s'explique par des caractéristiques
propres au territoire insulaire capacité
de stockage et d'épop pétroliers de
Lille insuffisante en été et
configuration oligo-polistique du
secteur de la distribution des
carburants aussi je souhaite vous
demander quel serait les mesures
complémentaires envisagées par votre
entreprise pour assurer une contribution
une distribution pardon optimale de
carburant sur ce type de territoire
particulièrement exposé en cas de
poursuite voire d'aggravation des
tensions sur la production mondiale de
pétrole comment par ailleurs mettre en
place de telle mesure sans déséquilibrer
des marchés en situation d'oligopole je
vous remercie
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole maintenant et pour le groupe
écologiste et apparenté à Madame sebahi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
pouyanais permettez-moi d'abord de me
réjouir au nom de mon groupe de votre
venue devant cette commission je suis
ravie de vous voir vous exprimer
aujourd'hui face à la représentation
nationale que vous aviez évité la
dernière fois même si nous ne faisons
pas partie de vos actionnaires il est
essentiel de vous entendre tant votre
implication dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique doit être
totale monsieur pouyanais lorsque l'on
consulte le site Internet de Total à la
page des valeurs de l'entreprise on peut
y lire être un acteur responsable du
monde de l'énergie c'est aussi
contribuer au bien-être des populations
de la planète je dois vous dire que
c'est assez ironique aujourd'hui tant
vos projets et vos investissements sont
décriés par les populations locales ou
encore par les acteurs institutionnels
monsieur pouyanet quelle contribution
bien-être des populations totales en
temps joué quand votre présence en
Russie maintenue jusqu'à la fin de l'été
et encore aujourd'hui dans une propotion
résiduelle a permis à l'entreprise au
cours des 9 premiers mois de l'année de
percevoir 748 millions de dollars de
dividendes des actifs réussi largement
décriée par plusieurs acteurs citoyens
et institutionnels comment
définissez-vous ce maintien d'activité
en contribution au bien-être des
populations monsieur pouyanais quelle
contribution au bien-être des
populations totales en temps jouer quand
l'entreprise projette de construire en
nous gandin un oléoduc qui précipite
dans la misère plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de paysans expulsés dans leur
terre selon Amnesty International
84000 personnes sont toujours en attente
de l'indemnisation qu'il aurait dû à
nouveau ce projet largement et
unanimement condamné et combattu par les
populations locales est-il une
contribution au bien-être des
populations de la planète quel projet de
société votre groupe porte alors que
l'oléoduc ecope rejettera 34000 tonnes
de CO2 par an quand l'agenda de la COP
27 peine à trouver des engagements
contraignants dans l'application des
accords de Paris ce même projet
occasionnera également des dégâts
irrémédiats sur la biodiversité des
réserves naturelles traversées en
Ouganda et en Tanzanie sommes-nous ici
face un acteur responsable du monde de
l'énergie monsieur pouyanet nous sommes
habitués ici au discours bien rodé sur
la transition écologique mais la vérité
que cela n'intéresse pas la plupart des
industriels pour beaucoup d'entre eux
ces auditions doivent leur permettre de
continuer à cacher une réalité les
énergies fossiles représentent encore
une écrasante majorité de leurs
activités dans le cas de total ces
90%. on pourrait presque croire à du
greenwashing de votre part si vous aviez
réellement compris que l'avenir de notre
planète est en jeu que l'avenir de nos
enfants est en péril vous auriez écouté
ce que tous les experts climatiques
répètent en boucle depuis des années
plus aucun nouveau projet d'énergie
fossile ne doit être lancé plus aucun
alors pour conclure monsieur pouyanais
nous aimerions vous voir retirer
l'affirmation mensongère de votre site
qui pour rappel vous décrit comme acteur
responsable du monde de l'énergie et
contributeur du bien-être des
populations de la planète car non
seulement vous faites partie des plus
gros pollueurs de la planète mais vous
êtes à rebours de la volonté des
populations locale et un robot de la
lutte contre l'urgence climatique
je vous remercie je crois que le
président avait répondu avait répondu à
votre question sur les énergies fossiles
monsieur Lecoq pour la Gauche démocrate
et républicaine
merci monsieur le Président
et j'ai vécu total pendant 60 ans je
connais bien votre entreprise et
aujourd'hui je répète pas tout ce qui a
été dit sur
Mozambique etc mais prenons l'exemple du
port
métallier du Havre terminal flottant la
ministre venir unias c'était engagé à
faire des études de danger comme si
c'était
les CPE c'est à dire comme si on avait
posé le bateau sur le quai
pour voir ce que ça donnait puisque le
code maritime ne donne pas les mêmes
conséquences des études de danger vos
spécialistes pourront vous l'expliquer
or soit total soit le préfet enfin il y
a quelqu'un qui apparaît respecté la
parole de la ministre puisque nous a
fait des on a présenté la population des
dangers
uniquement d'un bateau usine et pas
d'une usine qui serait avec les mêmes
caractéristiques mais construite sur sur
le quai donc pourquoi faire ça ensuite
on nous prévoit en prévoir importer des
gaz de schiste américain alors que la
France l'Assemblée nationale ici a voté
que nous n'accepterions jamais d'en
produire et donc je sais pas vous
puisque le président aime bien les
dictons moi je connais c'est pas ma
culture mais on dit toujours ne fait pas
aux autres ce que tu ne veux pas que
l'on te fasse et donc pourquoi importer
des gaz de schiste pourquoi permettre la
dégradation environnementale dans
certains pays pour pouvoir en faire
profiter les gens ici
on sera vigilant on a empêché des
bateaux saoudiens de venir charger des
canons Césars au Havre l'écluse François
1er il faudra la traverser avec un
navire corps à charger des gazochistes
ce sera pas si simple avec la population
à Brest d'autres disques ce projet
métallier était prévu avant la guerre en
Ukraine des voix s'élèvent pour dénoncer
ça c'est vous qui allez nous dire si si
c'était vrai ou si c'était pas vrai il y
avait des documents datés qui laissaient
apparaître que c'était avant la guerre
en Ukraine donc des vraies questions
pour nous et puis
et puis vous dites aussi que la France
serait plus en mesure avec ses
raffinerie et vous ne seriez plus en
mesure de produire suffisamment les
carburants utilisés en France et que
nous serions obligés d'importer des
produits finis
hors mes camarades de la raffinerie de
Gonfreville-l'Orcher qui était en lutte
jusqu'à il y a pas longtemps ce sont
battus et j'étais toujours à leurs côtés
pour expliquer qu'il fallait garder les
outils de production raffinerie de
Dunkerque raffiné grand puis pour que
soit produit en France et c'est vous qui
tout de suite dans votre présentation
préalable avait dit qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce pays qui laisse partir les
productions le microprocesseur à
l'étranger les photosvoltaïques à
l'étranger et tout et bien vous votre
groupe il a laissé partir la production
de l'essence de France vers l'étranger
et donc comment vous expliquer ces deux
poids de mesure et ses discours à deux
vitesses que vous nous présentez ce
matin et moi j'ai toujours été fier de
Total j'ai toujours été fier de l'emploi
que ça crée de la richesse que ça crée
dans la ville que j'administré des
conséquences que ça avait sur les
populations mais aujourd'hui votre
politique à travers le monde la
multinationale que vous êtes et moi je
défends l'idée de la loi de du devoir de
vigilance loi française qui dit que vous
devez faire attention aux populations et
un environnement qu'en pensez-vous je
vous remercie monsieur monsieur le
député maintenant pour le groupe
le liotte madame est celle du soufflant
merci monsieur
aux questions de la représentation
nationale élue de la première
circonscription de Mayotte je souhaite
vous interroger sur deux sujets qui nous
concernent directement Mayotte est une
terre française au cœur du canal du
Mozambique qui brille des ressources
gazières exceptionnelles dont Total à
certains contrats d'exploitation les
attaques de daesh vous ont poussé à
interrompre vos opérations et si la
situation semble actuellement maîtrisée
la question se pose de la reprise de vos
activités au Mozambique comme vous
l'avez justement souligné pour l'Afrique
le péril l'environnemental est supplanté
par l'urgence du développement
économique et l'aspiration légitime à
vivre dignement en construisant une
croissance durable et génératrice de
richesse partagée nous savons que ce
développement économique pour la région
et vitale pour lutter contre la pauvreté
et le terrorisme en tant qu'investisseur
en tant qu'investisseur créateurs
d'emplois et de savoir-faire total et
très attendu localement pour partenariat
gagnant-gagnant d'autant plus que ces
approvisionnements supplémentaires aux
ambiquens pour être à terme être une
solution importante pour la sécurité
énergétique européenne
Mayotte est à 500 km de votre base et
chantier de Cabaud d'algado Mayotte soit
accueillir une partie de vos équipes en
intégrant notre port de longonie dans
votre chaîne de valeur nous espérons que
votre entreprise française choisira
d'associer un territoire français à ce
projet riche en opportunité mon
interrogation est donc la suivante quant
total va-t-elle reprendre ses opérations
au Mozambiques et allez-vous intégrer
Mayotte à vos projets gaziers ma seconde
question concerne votre activité de
vente au détail Mayotte à Mayotte total
bénéficie d'une situation de monopole ce
privilège lui impose des obligations et
le geste commercial consenti par votre
groupe à la pompe a eu un impact positif
sur notre île ce dont nous en sommes
très reconnaissants mais notre autre
requête pour lutter contre la vie chère
et rester sans réponse nous avions
demandé une diminution du tarif de vente
du kérosène aérien
selon les compagnies d'aviation qui
opèrent à Mayotte total vend le kérosène
aérien sur place beaucoup plus cher
qu'ailleurs et cela rend chéri
considérablement le prix des billets
d'avion que nous payons au prix fort
ce qui est pour Total un mini
micromarché à un impact immédiat sur le
quotidien de la population de Mayotte
qui doit prendre l'avion pour se soigner
pour étudier pour travailler à
l'extérieur monsieur pouillané vous
l'aurez compris ma question est la
suivante allez-vous baisser le prix du
kérosène aérien et permettre le
désenclavement de vos compatriotes de
Mayotte je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la députée au titre des
non inscrits mais pour elle seule madame
Ménard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
PDG tout juste de retour de la COP 27 en
Égypte hier le président Macron a réuni
les dirigeants des 56 industriels
français les plus émetteurs de CO2 et
parmi ces sites il y avait les
raffineries évidemment d'aixon mobile et
total énergie en Normandie et je crois
que vous y étiez monsieur le PDG pour
remédier à ces pollutions il faut
changer de source d'énergie en
abandonnant les jeunes les énergies
fossiles pour se tourner vers
l'électricité de non-né maîtrise de CO2
cela suppose évidemment des
investissements massifs susceptibles de
d'augmenter les coûts de production et
de fragiliser la compétitivité des
entreprises concernées face à une
concurrence beaucoup moins pressée elle
de ce décarboner alors sans être public
ce sont des filières entières qui
risquent de disparaître en France ma
question est simple qu'attendez-vous de
l'État pour parvenir à cette
décarbonation et est-ce que les 10
milliards d'euros qui sont promis par
l'Élysée seront suffisants quand on sait
que la concurrence est d'ailleurs je
crois que proposer dans Macron il a fait
allusion notamment par les États-Unis va
être féroce je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le Président poulianet
vous avez été interpellé tous côtés la
réponse est à vous bon je vais je vais
prendre dans l'ordre de parlementaires
un exercice
non je vais essayer d'aller aussi vite
que vous multiplié par vous tous non
mais c'est compliqué
ça aurait été plus rapide c'est un
exercice passe simple
monsieur vivait bon monsieur Viber je
pense que vous me posez vous avez
posé une question en fait sur total
d'énergie et bien compris la transition
énergétique bon encore une fois je vais
le répéter vous pouvez m'accuser de dire
qu'on s'occupe pas des énergies des
carbonées je voulais savoir quel est le
groupe français qui investissent plus
que nous dans les énergies renouvelables
si vous le trouvez vous le montrez
il faut beaucoup d'équipes pour faire
des je vais manger renouvelables on en
recrute on augmente régulièrement nos
équipes nous sommes nous avons
maintenant 10000 personnes qui
travaillent en secteur ce sont chaque
projet est un effort et pas seulement
dans notre pays mais partout dans le
monde donc aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
l'argent qui nous limite c'est notre
capacité à trouver des projets à les
faire et à les développer si on est
d'ailleurs allé dans ce champ des
énergies renouvelables d'électricité
parce qu'on pense qu'il y a un potentiel
de croissance très important et
notamment dans dans l'ensemble de dire
l'ensemble des vies puisque beaucoup de
pays ont des projets donc encore une
fois bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes
aujourd'hui un groupe pétrolier je sais
pas changer moi aussi d'un coup c'est
parce que j'investis 4 milliards par an
pendant 10 ans que j'arriverai à faire
20% d'électricité d'origine renouvelable
en 2030 effectivement c'est ça la
stratégie de l'entreprise et c'est aussi
la stratégie c'est en 2050 que
l'électricité représentera plus de 50%
de notre production donc on nous sommes
35 transformer un producteur d'énergie
fossile pétrole et gaz dans notre
producteur d'électricité décarbonée et
par ailleurs comme nous l'avons décrit
dans notre portefeuille il y aura à peu
près 25% qui seront des molécules
décarbonées comme de l'hydrogène des
fioules synthétiques etc et les
hydrocarbures ne représenteront plus
sans doute que 25% de ce portefeuille
comme d'ailleurs en ligne avec le fameux
scénario de laïeux qui en 2050 continue
à avoir une production d'hydrocarbures
d'à peu près 20 à 25% de mix mondial
voilà le plan qu'on a alors après on
peut me dire c'est pas passé vite on va
passer de 1 milliard à 2 milliards à 4
milliards en trois ans alors vous partez
de rien et que vous êtes censé
construire des équipes parce que c'est
pas les milliards qui font les projets
c'est les hommes et les femmes que vous
avez besoin de remettre en oeuvre de
former de recruter et nous le faisons
dans beaucoup de pays au monde voilà ce
que je voulais dans le premier lieu
deuxième point et donc oui nous sommes
engagés dans cette stratégie mais comme
je l'ai expliqué par ailleurs une
deuxième commentaire vous pouvez
regarder mon mes investissements de deux
façons quels sont les vraiment projets
nouveaux que nous faisons et puis
qu'est-ce qui maintient le système
un système industriel de la taille que
nous avons qui produit
1,5 à 2% de l'énergie mondiale parce que
c'est notre part de marché côté pétrole
et gaz ça réclame effectivement des
milliards chaque année juste pour le
maintenir ça réclame à peu près 8
milliards et quand je regarde ce que je
fais des autres 8 milliards la moitié
verront dans les énergies des carbonées
et la moitié des nouveaux projets vont
dans les énergies fossiles et j'ai
expliqué pourquoi je dois faire des
nouveaux projets dans les intervie
fossiles c'est parce que je lutte contre
un déclin parce que la demande est
toujours là et que par ailleurs sur le
gaz naturel liquéfié nous avons
effectivement parce que le gars se
substitue au Charbon Pour faire de
l'électricité
95% de nos clients
qui achètent notre gaz naturel liquéfié
c'est pour substituer du charbon par du
gaz
95%. c'est une contribution transitoire
certes mais au changement climatique une
centrale à gaz émet deux fois moins de
CO2 qu'une centrale à charbon donc ce
gaz que vous décriez et bien il
contribue à la au fait que l'atmosphère
reçoit moins de CO2 chaque fois que je
que je produise parce que c'est une
notion de d'émission éviter mais qui est
quand même essentielle dans le débat
bien sûr qu'il est transitoire mais il
faut prendre en compte cette étape c'est
positif donc le gaz énergie transition
est un apport positif à la question du
changement climatique au moindre les 20
prochaines années après il faudra verdir
le gaz on passera l'hydrogène on passera
l'ammoniac on passera à d'autres moyens
de le produire et et insister électrique
qui ne serait qu'intermittent
vous ne serez pas content
ça je vous garantis si on doit expliquer
à nos concitoyens qui n'ont de
l'électricité quand il fait soleil où il
y a du vent il faut bien évidemment
l'accompagner autrement je suis désolé
on peut tous raconter des histoires mais
ce sont des histoires pour pouvoir faire
de l'électricité fiable il faut des
moyens de production flexibles et les
meilleurs moyens de productions que nous
avons aujourd'hui ce sont des centrales
à gaz on peut aussi faire du nucléaire
qui est le choix de la France qui n'est
pas d'ailleurs à moins flexible qui est
un moyen de base il nous faut et
d'ailleurs en France on a aussi besoin
de centrales à gaz donc on peut tous
vouloir tous en même temps dire Yaka
mais ce n'est pas la vérité de la
modification d'un système énergétique
ce n'est pas comme ça que ça va se
passer
le Mozambique Monsieur François voulait
poser question précise bon je trouve que
nous connaissons de ces Roanne donova
bon d'abord vous avez dit la vérité la
France adopté une loi qui nous interdit
qui interdit à quiconque sur le
territoire français de rechercher des
hydrocarbures nous respectons l'État de
droit dans lequel nous sommes
donc c'est un d'une choix fait par la
représentation par le mentale qui a été
votée nous le respectons donc personne
n'ira chercher les hydrocarbures et les
vieux permit titulaires personne n'aura
d'autorisation pour aller chercher dans
les îles épars sur les îles glorius il
se trouve que c'est un sujet qu'on a
regardé un certain temps et dont nous
sommes repartis après avoir avec une des
sociétés dont vous avez parlé travailler
pour voir s'il y avait un intérêt il y
avait pas d'intérêt par ailleurs encore
une fois le Parlement français ayant
décidé qu'il fallait pas rechercher les
recarbures sur le territoire national le
sujet s'est arrêté pour être complet par
rapport à votre propos
les avis de mes experts de nos experts
c'est qu'il y a pas un potentiel de la
taille de celui que vous avez décrit
donc je pense qu'on peut les aider les
isparres c'est les ill glorieuses comme
un sanctuaire de biodiversité
je parlais du Mozambique
je pense que
pour répondre à Madame tout de suite bon
la reprise du projet du Mozambique pose
plusieurs questions moi ma première
responsabilité d'ailleurs dans beaucoup
de dossiers
dominent c'est la sécurité du personnel
de Total énergie je ne vais pas engager
des gens on a dû évacuer en avril 2021
des milliers de personnes non seulement
nous mais des civils on va pas reprendre
la décision de remettre en chantier est
une décision qui est compliquée c'est à
dire explique beaucoup de positions que
nous avons prises au cours des dernières
années lorsqu'on met du temps à sortir
de Russie ou du mial mars c'est aussi
parce que ma première préoccupation
c'est pas d'exposer le personnel que
j'ai dans ces pays et que tant que je
n'ai pas trouvé les conditions pour les
protéger ou les évacuer j'évite de faire
de la politique rapidement même si je ne
soutiens pas les régimes en question
donc pour votre question donc est-ce
qu'on peut reprendre c'est une décision
qu'on prendra sans doute la première
moitié 2023 et qui pour moi veut dire
que l'on considérera que l'on a retrouvé
des conditions de sécurité durables dans
le cabaudel Gado ça veut dire notamment
que et nous l'avons dit au gouvernement
vous invite nous voulons que les
populations puissent vivre normalement
que des administrations fonctionnent que
une activité économique redémarre c'est
parce que la meilleure sécurité c'est
quand même quelque part que les
personnes puissent vivre normalement et
pas que il n'est pas question que nous
reprenions ce projet entouré par une
armée nous ne referons pas ce projet-là
alors si nous le faisons Mayotte en
profitera je vous le dis et on ne
l'avions prévu puisque d'ailleurs la en
liaison avec les trois avec le
gouvernement qui nous l'avait demandé
nous avons prévu que une base notamment
pour la partie des flexibles sous-marins
serait installés à bayot avec un des
contracteurs nous avons prévu que
Mayotte pourrait servir d'ailleurs de
base arrière d'évacuation et donc ils
ont pris investir dans l'hôpital à
Mayotte pour pouvoir puisque finalement
c'était plus rapide pour nous d'évacuer
en cas de d'accidents de blessés sur
Mayotte que sur ma Poutou qui est plus
loin donc oui Mayotte on pense Mayotte
quand on pense à ce projet on avait
aussi prévu qu'un câble est un câble
électrique sous-marin pour les problèmes
téléphoniques avec Orange ils reliraient
notre projet à Mayotte donc il y a vous
êtes bien dans notre souci enfin vous
êtes bien alors après est-ce qu'on
reprendra le projet je peux pas me
prononcer aujourd'hui
j'ai d'ailleurs dit à mes équipes que
nous le reprendrons que le jour où il
m'autoriseront au moins à aller au Cabot
d'elgado à traverser à prendre la
fameuse route de 100 km et avoir les
personnes sur le terrain je pense être
un bon test parce que tant que mes
équipes de sécurité me diront pas y
aller je vais pas y envoyer le personnel
et les contracteurs total énergie voilà
où on en est on me dit que je pourrais
peut-être y aller au premier trimestre
vous verrez après
sur le deuxième question de Mayotte
pardon je suis pas au courant donc je
prends le point moi personne on m'a
sollicité sur le rabais et j'ai dit
Mayotte en bénéficie bien évidemment
mais je n'étais pas au courant je prends
votre point et nous vous reviendrons par
écrit sur le point de kérosène je
reviens maintenant alors madame panot
sans poser des questions on a posé 10
donc je sais pas si je vais utiliser les
mêmes métaphores pour répondre à chacune
d'elles je vais quand même revenir sur
l'Ouganda moi j'en ai un peu assez
d'entendre qu'il y a 100 000 personnes
ou 100000 foyers monsieur fort qui sont
déplacés
alors je vais vous donner les chiffres
réels parce que c'est bien beau de faire
maintenant d'expliquer des choses sur
Twitter etc et dire c'est la vérité la
vérité n'est pas celle-là j'aurais adoré
que le Parlement européen nous invite à
nous expliquer je ne comprends pas nos
systèmes démocratiques dans lequel des
gens prennent des résolutions sans même
invités la principale partie prenante
pour lui poser des questions parce que
j'aurai répondu aux questions et
j'aurais évité au Parlement européen de
se discréditer j'ai décidé de vous le
dire en prenant en prenant une
résolution écoutez oui je sais fort et
je l'ai écrit à madame la présidente du
Parlement européen oui en prenant une
résolution sans écouter moi je savais
que je croyais que dans un état droit je
croyais que dans un état de droit je
croyais que dans un état de droit le
principe du contradictoire était
fondamental et qu'avant d'accuser
quelqu'un d'accuser une organisation sur
un sujet qui relève de la souveraineté
au passage de l'Ouganda et de
l'enterreénie
on pouvait demander aux personnes de
venir s'expliquer personne ne nous a
jamais demandé on nous a demandé après
que la résolution était votée devenue on
m'a demandé de venir pour 8 minutes nous
expliquer sur un sujet qui mérite bien
évidemment plus de temps voilà ce qui
s'est passé au Parlement européen et oui
j'ai écrit à madame la présidente du
Parlement européen j'ai rendu
public-tête que dans ces conditions-là
puisque le jugement était déjà rendu on
voyait pas très bien pourquoi il fallait
entrer qu'on justifie quelque chose qui
n'était pas le cas bien évidemment il
n'y a pas 100000 foyers de déplacés en
Ouganda donc je vais vous donner les
chiffres exacts le nombre de foyers qui
sont concernés par la nécessité de les
reloger et une reconstruisons des
maisons et de 769 foyers
769 voyez vous pouvez dire c'est
beaucoup oui
769 pas 100000 foyers donc cette
politique qui consiste aujourd'hui au
21e siècle à affirmer des choses et à
dire que c'est la vérité parce qu'on ne
passe pas notre temps à à dire non ce
n'est pas vrai c'est 769 foyers j'en ai
le décompte à la fois en Ouganda et qui
vont être effectivement déplacés et pour
lesquels nous reconstruisons des maisons
d'ailleurs 98% où nous les indivisions
financièrement 95% d'entre eux
choisissent qu’on leur reconstruise des
maisons voilà ce qui se passe en ce
moment ça prend du temps le projet est
long effectivement mais nous le faisons
et nous le faisons bien évidemment le
respect des droits humains
dire que nous ne respectons pas les
droits humains il se trouve qu'il y a
des valeurs dans cette entreprise et il
n'y a pas l'unanimité de la population
ougandaise qui est contre ce n'est pas
vrai ça c'est des affirmations ici
l'unanimité de la population la grande
majorité de ce projet et favorable au
projet bien sûr qu'il peut y avoir des
personnes qui sont contre comme dans
toutes démocratie et nous ce qui sont
avec elle
non mais ce n'est pas 100 000 foyers qui
sont déplacés c'est 769
mais vous vérifierez effectivement vous
verrez sur la base de nos chiffres qu'on
vous fournit puisque c'est nous-même qui
a les aliments
après il y a pour fille pour être
complet sur les personnes déplacées
après il y a des terres agricoles je
continue il y a des terres agricoles des
gens qui possèdent des terres que nous
devons indemniser que nous l'indemnisons
pas du tout à 1000 dollars par hectare
comme je l'ai entendu en Ouganda mais
plus cher que ça à un prix relativement
élevé
et le nombre de paires de terre
agricoles de personnes concernées par
des terres agricoles que nous devons
effectivement compenser et de 19000
voilà voilà les chiffres 770 personnes
69 foyers doivent être déplacés et 19000
personnes au 18 000 sont concernés par
le fait que ils ont des terres et que
18000 terre donc 18000 foyers si vous
voulez mais ils sont pas déplacés ils ne
sont pas non ils ne sont pas déplacés
ils ne sont pas déplacés
ils ne sont pas déplacés monsieur je
suis désolé
ils ne sont pas déplacés voilà donc
l'Ouganda est un projet
dont je viens de donner des chiffres qui
est important
il n'y a pas de jugement géant en
Afrique du Sud je sais pas c'est une
invention il y a pas de gisement géant
en Afrique du Sud non ce n'est pas vrai
il y a un peu de gaz dont on sait pas
d'ailleurs comment on peut le
commercialiser sur le marché j'ai
rencontré je suis dans l'Afrique du Sud
de la semaine dernière et ils ont été
autorités d'Afrique du Sud effectivement
on s'interroge à savoir parce qu'en
Afrique du Sud se trouve qu'il n'y a pas
de réseau gazier donc c'est compliqué
quand vous trouvez du gaz d'arriver à le
commercialiser
alors votre question portée sur la
trajectoire climatique totale énergie je
crois c'était finalement à la fin de
votre question si je vis à noter
écoutez moi je m'en remets à son de gens
qui évaluent nos propres trajectoires
on n'a jamais dit trois à trois et demi
on a dit simplement c'est pas trop à
trois et demi c'est pas totalement
énergie c'est la c'est pas nous qui
l'avons dit c'est que l'accord de Paris
qu'on faisait la somme des contributions
nationales de chacun des pays l'a eu à
chiffrer ce que la somme des
contributions nationales donnés et a dit
on est sur une trajectoire 3 et 3 et
demi pas nous qui l'avons dit ça c'est
la somme des contributions nationales de
l'époque depuis il y a eu d'autres il y
a son de pays qui sont engagés sur Net 0
et on sait que la trajectoire on est
plutôt à 2,2,3 degrés
le CDP le CDP le CDP qui est l'organisme
qui évalue nos programmes récemment je
viens crois viens je veux dire en
rapport disait que nous étions sur une
trajectoire de Deville 1 à 2,2 degrés
c'est pas nous qui le disons la
transition patrouille initiative qui a
évalué les programmes de 50 entreprises
pétrolière nous a classé parmi les trois
entreprises qui avions une trajectoire
compatible avec une atteinte du net0 ça
c'est des faits c'est-à-dire c'est pas
nous qui l'affirmons sont des ce sont
des auditeurs extérieurs qui qui le
disent et qui évalue l'ensemble des
trajectoires des entreprises pétrolières
et dans le monde pétrolier aujourd'hui
encore une fois vous allez me dire que
c'est pas assez il y a encore eu Reuters
là encore dit il y a deux jours nous
sommes de loin celui qui investissons le
plus dans les énergies décarbonées et ce
qui pose d'ailleurs débat avec un
certain nombre de mes actionnaires
aujourd'hui donc bien sûr qu'on peut
toujours faire plus mais je je considère
que l'entreprise s'est mis sur une
trajectoire qui est audacieuse et qui
doit nous entraîner et doit faire en
sorte que nous viendrons un acteur
majeur de ces énergies là
sur monsieur c'est un G je pense oui bon
la Russie non la Russie n'est pas
importante pour Total énergie si nous
restons et je vais reprendre ça me
permet de répondre à Madame sebahi s'il
nous restons si nous continuons à
approvisionner à rester en Russie c'est
effectivement parce qu'on a un contrat
de gaz naturel qui est fier et c'est
pour le bien-être des populations
européennes c'est pour assurer la
sécurité d'approvisionnement de l'Europe
la Russie cette année c'est 2% du cash
flow total énergie si vous pensez que le
PDG est totale énergie n'a pas envie
d'arrêter cette fausse situation pour 2%
de notre cash flow
c'est simplement que ce contrat
aujourd'hui si nous arrêtons d'ailleurs
pour l'arrêter je ne sais pas le faire
unilatéralement parce que j'ai un
engagement dans les secondes ce cas
naturelle est kéfié mais si nous
l'arrêtons la situation de l'Europe qui
a cette année importé 70% du gaz naturel
qui est virus ne s'améliorera pas du
tout nous ne savons pas le substituer
total énergie à nos bornes nous pouvons
partir de Russie demain matin d'ailleurs
depuis le début de l'année nous nous
sommes désengagés progressivement de
tout ce qui n'avait pas de tous les
contrats tous les projets tous les
champs qui avaient uniquement une
vocation domestique
de chants domestiques nous en sommes
sortis il ne nous reste aujourd'hui que
une participation dans l'usine de Yama
LNG et ce fameux contrat gaz naturel
n'est pas qui est un contrat européen et
un engagement pour pouvoir nous en
sortir il y a deux solutions soit les
autorités qui est pas totalement
impossible viennent de le faire sur
d'autres groupes occidentaux soit
l'Europe décide de sanctionner le gaz
russe l'Europe n'a pas décidé gaz russe
parce que et l'Europe et leader européen
avec qui nous sommes en relation nous
continuons à amener ce gaz naturel et
qui fait en Russie donc faut pas se
tromper c'est pas un problème pour Total
énergie d'ailleurs nous avons présenté
fin septembre le futur de Total énergie
toute la stratégie sans la Russie à
l'ensemble de nos actionnaires on leur
dit voilà comment ce qu'on voilà ce que
c'est que Total RJ en Russie et ce n'est
pas un problème nous n'avons pas investi
20 milliard nous en avions investi 15 et
c'était pas un pays majeur c'était 10%
de nos capitaux c'est beaucoup mais s'il
se trouve que chez nous pour gérer le
risque géopolitique qui existe
nous avons une espèce de règle du pouce
et que nous ne voulons pas qu'un pays
fasse plus de 10% de notre portefeuille
nous venons de le démontrer et donc et
effectivement nous avons déjà éliminé
dans nos comptes cette année à peu près
10 milliards de pertes sur les 15
milliards 10 milliards ont été passés en
perte au fur et à mesure de l'année et
sans doute il y aura une suite à cela
voilà la situation russe elle est
motivée uniquement aujourd'hui par la
responsabilité d'amener ce gaz naturel
qui est fier ici en Europe et si
l'Europe décide de sanctionner nous
arrêterons immédiatement nous pourrons
le faire et nous et nous nous renonceur
encore une fois d'ailleurs sur le plan
financier je peux vous dire que la
plupart des 700 millions de dollars que
quelqu'un madame s'ébahi a mentionné
sont arrivés avant le premier trimestre
parce que les flux financiers entre la
Russie et l'Europe une fois que bien
évidemment nous respectons toutes les
sanctions et que nous veillons à ne
faire aucune erreur c'est assez
compliqué à donc les questions n'est pas
financière la question c'est
d'approvisionner aujourd'hui l'Europe
par ce gaz naturel qui est
pour et alors la stratégie sur la Russie
la stratégie dans la Russie c'est le
reste c'est la rue c'est les États-Unis
notamment puisque il se trouve que les
États-Unis pour nous correspondent
exactement à nos stratégie qui a deux
piliers gaz naturels liquéfier et
renouvelable et nous venons cette année
nous sommes le premier exportateur de
gaz naturel qui fit américaine
et d'ailleurs l'Europe en a bénéficié
oui c'est vrai on a assuré cette année
l'approvisionnement de l'Europe part du
gaz naturel et américains puisque nous
sommes aussi le premier
détenteur de capacité de
regazidification en Europe donc on l'a
amené pour approvisionner l'Europe et
nous avons aussi des sommes devenus le
numéro 5 américain des énergies
renouvelables en rachetant une société
aux États-Unis cette année donc les
États-Unis font partie de la politique
il y a d'autres pays où nous redéployons
nos capitaux comme le Brésil avec
exactement d'ailleurs la même stratégie
puisqu'on a annoncé il y a 8 jours que
nous venons de rentrer dans une société
avec le plus gros développeur éolien
nous en avons
reprises monter à 50% et où aussi nous
développons des hydrocarbures au Brésil
donc Brésil Brésil
États-Unis Inde également nous venons
d'investir 5 milliards d'années dans un
mix gaz et énergie renouvelable avec
donc voilà on redéploie on redéploie nos
capitaux sur d'autres zones où on peut
appliquer notre stratégie à la fois gaz
et énergie renouvelable
alors je j'ai répondu je pense à
Monsieur zinski à
aux divers sujets à travers les
questions encore une fois je vous le
répète oui nous sommes racheté ça oui
grâce à staffe nous sommes rentrés dans
une société avec stellantis et Mercedes
qui s'appelle s.cc pour faire des
batteries pour véhiculer électrique on
espère en faire un acteur majeur des
batteries pour véhiculer électrique au
niveau européen voire mondial on a
construit là un très fort partenariat
pour avec déjà une première giga vectory
dans le nord de la France qui est en
train de se construire il aura une
deuxième en Italie une troisième en
Allemagne et d'autres suivront vu les
ambitions de ces deux constructeurs de
ces constructeurs automobiles donc voilà
ça c'est une contribution très concrète
d'ailleurs à la mobilité électrique et
je vous ai redis je vous ai répondu je
pense à travers les chiffres que j'ai
donné sur nos niveaux de nos
investissements dans cette matière
j'ai répondu je pense alors Monsieur
fort non la RDC en l'occurrence il n'est
pas question je l'ai affirmé plusieurs
fois nous ne n'irons pas en RDC nous ne
sommes pas candidats il n'y aura pas de
RDC chez Total énergie pour diverses
raisons des raisons sécuritaires des
raisons évidentes au clair d'essai et
nous c'est non j'ai et j'ai beau le
répéter mais je vous le redis
solennellement il n'y aura pas total
énergie ne sera pas regardez c'est voilà
pour faire du pétrole et donc ce fameux
tuyau ne servira pas à faire cela
je pense avoir répondu
aux autres questions
madame sebahi m'a posé des questions
à la fois sur le bien-être sur la Russie
je pense avoir répondu sur lookanda je
vous ai également répondu d'ailleurs un
mot sur la biodiversité en Ouganda je
sais bien que on peut je l'ai déjà
expliqué on s'est engagé sur ce sujet là
à mener les actions qui soient qui nous
permettent de d'être avoir un gain net
positif comme le disent les experts
c'est très concret c'est qu'on travaille
par exemple en ce moment en Ouganda avec
des experts des scientifiques pour voir
comment on peut reconstituer des
corridors pour la circulation des
chimpanzés on va contribuer à accroître
de 50% les Rangers dans les parcs
nationaux d'Ouganda or le principal
sujet de la biodiversité dans ces pays
africains c'est le braconnage et que
mettre en place une police des parcs
nationaux à une vraie utilité pour la
biodiversité voilà les choses très
concrètes qu'on peut chercher à faire
Monsieur Le Coq non le projet alors je
veux dire ce projet de
n'existait absolument pas avant la
guerre les métagniers flottants je sais
pas qui a pu dire ça alors vraiment
c'était à 100 milieux de nos idées
pourquoi mais pour une raison simple
c'est que les terminaux regazidification
en Europe étaient remplis à peine 30 à
40%. si engie nous les a vendus en 2018
et c'était considéré comme des actifs
entre guillemets
[Musique]
très vulnérable pour pas très cher c'est
parce qu'ils étaient très peu utilisés
parce qu'en fait le gaz russe alimentait
l'Europe et que les terminaux de
regazification européen était au plus de
moitié vide et c'est pour ça qu'il en
manque aujourd'hui pourquoi on dit tout
d'un coup on découvre qu'il manque des
terminaux de rogazification de rock mais
parce qu'en fait il y avait pas de
marché pour il y avait du gaz russe ou
du gaz norvégien ou du gaz de mer du
Nord donc aucun d'entre nous n'avait
imaginé amené ce terminal avant ça je
vous le garantis il se trouve qu'à
partir mon la le conflit a eu lieu
tous les gouvernements européens se sont
mobilisés pour nous demander est-ce
qu'on peut faire quelque chose dans
notre flotte
hérité d'enji il y avait deux terminaux
flottants de regazification l'un a été
en Chine l'autre servait de méthanier et
donc nous avons dit à la France et à
l'Allemagne puisque le deuxième on veut
l'installer on va en train d'installer
en Allemagne que nous pouvions ramener
ces deux terminaux mais dans un acte je
dirais citoyen de sécurité
d'approvisionnement voilà ce qui s'est
passé total énergie à travers un
terminal regardification c'est une
infrastructure c'est pas ça va pas nous
rapporter beaucoup d'argent c'est pas le
sujet là on a vraiment que je considère
que nous avons fait un acte pour
contribuer à la sécurité
d'approvisionnement d'Europe en
substitution à l'abandon du gastrus
voilà ce qui s'est passé et là dans le
avec le gouvernement une fois qu'on leur
a dit qu'on l'avait un on a regardé où
on pouvait le localiser au mieux en
France on a comparé d'ailleurs fausse Le
Havre Dunkerque on a considéré que la Le
Havre avait offrait les meilleures
conditions pour aller vite parce que
bien évidemment la condition derrière ça
ne fait de sens continue de la crise que
nous nous vivons aujourd'hui que si on
est capable de mettre rapidement cette
infrastructures en place le gouvernement
a décidé dans le cas de la loi de qui
était votée par le Parlement fin juillet
de mettre des procédures accélérées
d'autorisation de façon à ce que se
terminal puisse rentrer en
fonctionnement milieu 2023 si je si je
les voilà ce qui s'est passé donc on est
vraiment là on est en train de alors
quel gaz naturel qui viendra dans ce
terminal il viendra il s'est dit il y
aura peut-être du Nigéria vous savez
nous produisons du gaz naturel et kiffé
dans dans 11 différents pays donc après
nous on gère l'ensemble de notre
portefeuille il peut venir il pourra
faire du Qatar éventuellement il viendra
du portefeuille que nous gérons oui on a
du gaz de schiste américain on en a
d'autres la réalité en ce moment c'est
que dans ces dossiers c'est comme je
disais au départ un conflit entre un
conflit comment rendre compatible la
nécessité nécessaire sécurité
d'approvisionnement du continent du pays
avec la durabilité et avec la la
le caractère abordable
et ce que j'observe c'est que la
première priorité tous les gouvernements
c'est assurer la sécurité
d'approvisionnement parce que les
citoyens si on leur dit qu'on va leur
couper le chauffage ou les crises c'est
un vrai problème voilà ce qui se passe
voilà donc je pense que
le gaz de schiste écouté je vais pas on
peut pas rentrer dans ce débat là par le
il est interdit en France il est
autorisé ailleurs et il se trouve qu'en
ce moment on en a besoin pour alimenter
l'Europe
mais c'est attendez mais si vous ne mais
il y a pas de problème le Parlement peut
décider d'interdire l'importation de gaz
naturel qui fait américain
non attendez c'est pas de l'éthique pas
mais c'est pas un problème pourquoi les
entreprises devraient madame faire ce
que ce qui relève de votre
responsabilité pourquoi pourquoi vous
nous demandez à nous alors que d'un côté
on nous demande d'alimenter l'Europe en
énergie on nous dit vous contribuez
directement à la sécurité
approvisionnement moi je peux pas je
peux pas inventer le gaz naturel
liquéfié il se trouve que gaz naturel
l'Amérique en produit un quart à peu
près aujourd'hui 20% du magasin qui est
fait mondial qu'il y a des capacités
disponibles je vais pas tout d'un coup
bien sûr quand même temps vous allez me
dire c'est le Qatar il se trouve qu'on
vient de dessiner des nouveaux contrats
au Qatar c'est pas du gasochiste c'est
au Qatar voilà donc on cherche à
diversifier notre portefeuille mais
aujourd'hui si on veut amener du gaz
naturel liquéfier en Europe il a 25% de
chance d'être venant des États-Unis ça
c'est la vérité c'est la réalité du
marché
et donc après l'alternative c'est de pas
l'amener et puis mais c'est pas moi qui
expliquerait à nos concitoyens français
que on l'a pas amené parce qu'on en a
pas alors qu'on en a
donc
voilà donc
bon je pense que je suis allé au bout
non vous m'avez demandé n'importe diesel
pourquoi on importe du diesel non mais
il est connu Monsieur Le Coq vous savez
très bien puisque vous connaissez très
bien le raffinage on apporte pas
d'essence en Europe on apporte pas des
sens on fait trop d'essence tout ça
c'est parce qu'on a un outil de
raffinage qui datait qui date que
l'Europe et la France notamment a fait
un choix extrêmement diesel à la
tournant des années 90 2000 qu'on s'est
retrouvé avec un déficit de diesel qu'on
importe la diesel russe ce qui est une
qui n'est pas si simple que ça et donc
c'est pas aujourd'hui
c'est pas la comment dire c'est pas
l'arrêt des raffineries qui nous pose un
problème de des ailes je veux dire on
n'a pas arrêté la raffinerie de
Normandie et on produit ce qu'on peut
après le diesel russe non mais je par
ailleurs moi je sur le raffinage on fait
face quand même alors c'est un des
sujets les plus complexes de transition
quand l'Europe décide qu'à partir de
2035 il n'y aura plus de véhicules
thermiques vendus il faut bien que nous
anticipions nous l'adaptation de notre
portefeuille industriel or une
raffinerie c'est beaucoup de monde non
seulement dans la raffinerie dans les
écosystèmes autour et donc ce que nous
cherchons de faire c'est de faire de la
transition en les transformant
d'ailleurs en biographie petit à petit
puisqu'on a besoin de faire de ou les
carburants aériens durables comme on l'a
fait à la mettre comme on le fait à
grandpuit et en même temps il faut qu'on
garde certaines raffineries les plus
importantes comme Normandie comme Donges
celles qui sont sur la façade les
façades maritimes qui sont les mieux
positionnées de façon à assurer la
sécurité une partie de la sécurité
approvisionnement du pays donc c'est ça
la difficulté c'est pas le sujet le plus
simple en terme de transition compte
tenu des évolutions des décisions qui
sont prises par les pouvoirs publics
voilà je pense avoir couvert l'essentiel
des questions vous avez tout à fait
répondu aux questions bien sûr madame
Ménard je l'ai mis dans un madame la
décarbonation qu'il faut répondre
on a un programme d'investissement on
vient d'annoncer qu'on accélère une
partie d'ailleurs de la de nos profits
c'est un programme d'un milliard sur
deux ans au niveau mondial pour
accélérer les bicarbonation dont 200
millions en France
pour accélérer la décarbonation et donc
je considère pas que je dois faire appel
au pouvoir public je de façon générale
alors il se trouve qu'il y a des projets
que nous faisons pas tout seul
conjointement avec d'autres entreprises
notamment sur l'hydrogène qui n'ont
absolument économique économie ou l'État
va nous accompagner accompagne on a des
projets avec Air Liquide on a des
projets avec engie on a des projets
d'hiver mais sur le reste la
décarbonation chez Total énergie je
considère cette totale énergie qui doit
la financer ça me paraît donc je serai
pas le principal les 10 milliards seront
pas ça me paraît assez normal de
continuer les conditions financières
enfin nos bénéfices de pas à faire
argent appel à l'argent public ça veut
pas dire qu'on va pas mettre en oeuvre
nos programmes par ailleurs on a nos
engagements on a nos objectifs et on va
les tenir
sachez que nous utilisons pour faire des
économies nous nous utilisons 100
dollars la tonne partout dans le monde
pour faire des projets efficacés
énergétiques qui fait que c'est la tonne
de carbone donc c'est un niveau qui
permet d'en faire beaucoup partout
bien je vous remercie j'ai entendu s'il
a une certaine impatience à l'idée vous
répondiez aux questions
personnellement je ne partage pas cette
impatience je trouve que les questions
ont été posées par le banquet par les
parlementaires vous y avez apporté des
réponses extrêmement intéressantes
contestables assurément par les uns et
par les autres mais extrêmement riche et
extrêmement intéressantes et je pense
que quand on pose des questions à la
moindre des choses c'est d'être
satisfait d'entendre des réponses
maintenant effectivement ça limite
considérablement les possibilités
d'intervention qui nous restent le
président puyanais
écoutez je vous en prie
c'est le moment de citer la célèbre
phase du président qui a signé l'accord
de Paris le président Fabius qui disait
on ne peut pas faire tenir 2 litres
d'eau dans une bouteille d'un litre et
on a on a très simplement monsieur
pouillané était
s’est engagé vis-à-vis de nous jusqu'à
12h30 les questions qu'on va lui poser
maintenant il faut qu'il ait le temps
d'y répondre donc on va lui laisser 5
minutes à 25 et donc il faudra tenir
dans les délais en question 12h45 12h45
je vous remercie ça nous aide ça c'est
pas une négociation c'est que j'ai
d'autres engagements non ça nous aide
considérablement et je propose je vais
dire j'ai beaucoup d'inscrits de
différents groupes je propose je peux
pas parler je propose que chacun parle
une minute et pas deux sinon ça ne
Servera pas et qu'on est deux mais
n'écoutez vous n'êtes pas seul vous
n'êtes pas seul dans cette commission
chacun doit prendre la parole et le
président que nous invitons doit pouvoir
répondre il faut quand même avoir un
sens de la collectivité dans cette
affaire alors je demande la parole je
donne la parole pour une
deux personnes
pour commencer une personne par groupe
et ensuite si j'ai un peu plus de temps
une seconde personne par groupe la
première inscrite à Madame Pompili
allez
si vous voulez monsieur Monsieur Le Gall
madame
je vais faire je vais faire du style
télégraphique monsieur le Président des
entreprises pour l'environnement d'abord
quand vous commencez votre intervention
ça me chagrine toujours d'entendre que
il faudrait ne pas s'occuper de nos
émissions dites marginales et ne
s'occuper que des émissions de la Chine
et de l'Inde sachant que nos émissions
viennent notamment de la Chine et de
l'Inde puisque quand on conduit des
voitures ou quand on dépense de
l'énergie ça vient très certainement
d'ailleurs et que nous avons une
responsabilité deuxième chose sur la
question du gaz
évidemment la transition ça prend du
temps et je suis d'accord avec vous sur
le défi prométhéin mais attention les
investissements dans le gaz ne peuvent
être que des investissements de
transition or comment faites-vous la
différence entre les investissements que
vous faites qui peuvent effectivement
permettre d'aider des pays qui sont
dépendants du charbon de ceux qui vont
nous refaire partir dans une boucle
pendant 20 30 40 50 ans parce que quand
on conduit quand on construit les tuyaux
de gaz c'est pas pour 5 ans et je pense
que c'est très important vous avons
arrêté les garanties export vous le
savez en France sur tous les projets
hors projets de gaz et de fioul ce que
ce qui me ce qui me déprime un petit peu
sur lesquels allez vous demander des
garanties export dans les années qui
viennent et dernier point qui est très
important monsieur le Président et à un
moment c'est difficile de le faire en
une minute
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
dans son rapport net 0 2050 avait été
très clair il ne faut plus maintenant de
nouveaux projets de création ou
d'extension d'exploitation de gisements
de gaz pétrole charbon au-delà de ce
déjà engagé en 2021 est-ce que vous avez
des projets au-delà de ce qui était
engagés en 2021 aujourd'hui qui nous
ferait exploser nos compteurs carbone et
dernier point est-ce que vous pensez un
jour et investir en Russie monsieur
la réponse est non nous n'avons dit plus
de nouveaux capital de Total énergie en
Russie il y a plus de vos capitales
export non la France a tout interdit
donc il y a pas de crédit export de la
France au tout projet fossile pour moi
c'est la l'état de la législation que tu
veux dire on va pas les demander y
compris gaz il me semble autant que en
tout cas j'en suis certain oui c'est là
ils ont évolué et premier point j'ai
déjà oublié non mais c'était aïeux vous
savez que à ce stade est-ce que j'ai des
nouveaux projets qui n'étaient pas lancé
en 2011 la réponse est NON je peux vous
démontrer que tous les projets nouveaux
sur lesquels nous travaillons existé
avant si c'est ça le sens de y compris
ça mais par contre comme vous savez que
je suis en désaccord avec le scénario
qui est faux parce que malheureusement
la demande de va pas au rythme encore
une fois la Ie c'est une trajectoire à
-4% par an la demande ne baisse pas de
-4% par an ce n'est pas vrai donc nous
ne sommes nous inscrivons pas dans la
trajectoire de laïeu nous ne nous
inscrivons pas nous l'avons expliqué le
site officiels nous l'avons écrit et là
et ce n'est pas une bible et une
religion tout ça moi dans le rapport du
GIEC dans le rapport du GIEC il y a 70
trajectoires différentes pour atteindre
la neutralité carbone 70 il y en a pas
une c'est pas vrai moi je l'ai lu le
rapport du 70 trajectoires différentes
il y en a 70 dans le rapport du GIEC et
on a décidé d'en prendre une seule une
seule qui est linéaire et décroissante
mais la planète n'est pas linéaire est
décroissante voilà donc nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec cette trajectoire non
c'est pas comme ça c'est qu'on pense
qu'à partir comme quelqu'un la monsieur
je pense monsieur Viber ou quelqu'un l'a
dit au tournant des années 203835 moi je
sais faire ramener ma production
d'hydrocarbures à 200000 barils par jour
il suffit qu'à 20323033 j'arrête
d'investir dans le pétrole je perds 4 à
5 % par an
donc je vais bien qu'on décide qu'il y a
une nouvelle bible mais il se trouve que
la Bible en l'occurrence n'est pas
conforme à la réalité de la demande
voilà c'est très clair vous l'avez
expliqué très clairement Monsieur David
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Directeur Général
[Musique]
le projet à Coop c'est 10 milliards de
dollars
les esropriations un et demi pour cent
4450 dollars par personne en Ouganda
1160 en Tanzanie il semblerait
d'ailleurs que
26% des Ougandais et 85% des temps
années attendent toujours d'être
dédommagé
s'attarde c'est et plus s'attarde plus
la spéculation est forte sur le prix du
foncier dans ces deux pays et moins les
les
expropriés ont la possibilité de
remployer les sommes accordées et donc
vous répondez simplement nous ne sommes
que des opérateurs du projet qui se
conformont loi et au règlement locaux et
nous ne sommes engagés à appliquer les
normes de la Banque mondiale c'est pas
une réponse pour ces populations c'est
vrai que vous devriez être beaucoup plus
proche de la réalité et en particulier
des dédommagements nécessaires pour ces
populations
en ce qui concerne les créations
d'emplois
vous parlez de 80000 créations d'emplois
mais est-ce que tous ces emplois vont
bénéficier à la population locale merci
je vous remercie vous répondez au
ping-pong
bon premièrement les réévaluations
pourquoi y a-t-il un délai d'abord parce
que le projet notamment le projet
concernant le tuyau n'a été décidé qu'en
début 2022 effectivement
le lancement de la partie je dirais
indemnisation ne se réalise que depuis
le début de l'année et il faut y aller
et on avance aussi vite que possible
pour indemniser les personnes c'est très
clair donc là-dessus je comprends bien
le souci le deuxièmement d'ailleurs les
indemnisations cotées ou Vendées ont été
réévalués au fil du temps donc une
réévaluation qui a été faite côté ou
Vendée pour tenir compte justement du
fait qu'entre le début puisque ça avait
même pris plus de temps côté hollandais
puisqu'à un moment l'état ougandais des
avaient demandé d'arrêter les
indemnisations donc on a dû les
reprendre deux ans plus tard ce qui a
créé d'ailleurs une source
d'insatisfaction et nous avons réévalué
ces ind petite enseignat c'est tout
nouveau puisqu'en fait situation est
très différente que le côté tanzanien
l'essentiel des terrains appartiennent à
l'État donc la situation des deux pays
est très très différente donc mais je
prends bien votre point et on a bien ça
en tête qu'il faut qu'on veille à ce que
l'indemnisation qu'on apporte permet
effectivement aux populations de pouvoir
retrouver leur terre agricole si c'est
une terre agricole encore une fois si
c'est un logement mais ils sont moins
concernés nous les relogions de manière
dans les quel que soit le coup voilà
donc nous partageons votre votre point
et votre souci
deuxièmement oui des 80 000 emplois sont
locaux oui on va pas on va pas apporter
80 000 emplois de l'extérieur c'est le
coup
la construction
de près mais après il y aura un ancien
nombre d'emplois qui doit alors là pour
le couple je sais pas comment il faut de
personnes pour faire le tuyau il doit
falloir 2 à 3000 personnes pour faire
fonctionner ces installations
oui c'est clair ce sont des emplois
techniciens et d'ingénieurs de
techniciens sont pas qualifiés oui bien
sûr
ils seront locaux vous savez j'ai pas le
nombre d'expatriés de Total énergie dans
ce genre d'opération souhaite une
centaine de cent pour avoir le projet et
une centaine après c'est pas on toutes
nos opérations s'appuient profondément
sur de l'emploi local et nous ayons en
général ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
profite des projets toute la phase de
construction pour mettre en place des
formations qui nous permettent d'avoir
les opérateurs locaux c'est fond de
c'est une demande légitime d'ailleurs
l'Ouganda est un pays qui insiste
beaucoup lait dessus ce qu'on appelle le
contenu local auquel nous prenons en
charge comme aujourd'hui j'étais en
Angola cette semaine en Angola sur 2500
personnes que nous employons il y a 2400
en Gauley
je vous remercie alors je n'ai plus ce
sont des emplois qui tiennent des
emplois de responsables techniques de
l'ensemble de nos opérations oui bien
sûr je n'ai plus ni monsieur le gars ni
madame auto 80000 pendant la phase de
construction je pense que c'est ce qui
est sur le site mais c'est ce qui est
écrit sur notre site je pense que c'est
ce qui est écrit dans toutes nos notes
merci Monsieur fort je n'ai plus 10 mala
Mouta ni Monsieur Le Gall madame
abomangoli vous
allez-y
permettez-moi de douter votre intégrité
au vu du rapport que votre groupe Total
énergie entretient vis-à-vis du reste du
monde lorsqu'il s'agit de stratégie
expansionnistes au détriment des droits
humains on se rappellera de votre
dilemme à quitté la Birmanie au prétexte
que vous y étiez installé depuis 92
alors que 780 organisations
internationales de la société civile et
un syndicat de travailleur étudiants
nous sommes nés de mettre fin à votre
complicité dans les crimes d'atrocité de
la gentille militaire birmane en
décembre 2021 on pourrait se dire que
vous avez appris de vos erreurs et voilà
que Total énergie est visée par une
plante pour complicité de crimes de
guerre en Ukraine selon un article du
Monde paru le 24 août qui se battait sur
plusieurs documents et une enquête de
l'OMG Global Witness total énergie a
contribué à l'alimentation d'avion russe
engagé dans le conflit en Ukraine au
moins jusqu'en juillet dernier en
Ouganda et en Tanzanie ne vous en
déplaise les ONG les Amis de la Terre et
survie dénoncent des violations des
droits humains touchants aujourd'hui
environ 5000 personnes privées de leur
terre beaucoup soulignent avoir signé
les formulaires de sélection de celle-ci
à la suite de pression et d'intimidation
de la part de Total et de ses
sous-traitants et vous comprendrez dans
ces conditions que nous pouvons croire
sur parole le Parlement européen se dit
vivement préoccupé par l'isolation des
droits de l'homme mais quoi de
surprenant Dickens Camu guicha président
de l'ONG African institut for énergie
gouvernance déclare à ce propos dans
toute l'Afrique il n'y a aucun des pays
pétroliers qui réussit à éviter la
violation des droits humains et
environnementaux monsieur pouillan est
combien de temps encore comptez vous
piétinez la Déclaration des droits de
l'homme pour vos propres intérêts et
pour ceux de l'entreprise totale et de
ses actionnaires merci c'est
heureusement qu'il y avait une question
la fin parce que c'est une séance de
questions
monsieur Guignot attends on va on
voulait répondre vous voulez répondre
je réponds que nous respecterons les
droits de l'homme
c'est une réponse laconique monsieur
Guignot vous voyez merci monsieur le
Président vous avez la parole merci très
très rapidement
nous avons écouté faites-en autant pour
les autres merci vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure monsieur le Président Directeur
Général depuis le conflit en Ukraine
nous avons bien sûr conscience des
difficultés importantes de la
prévisionnement en gaz mais le 5
décembre dernier Monsieur Macron
confirmé à la presse qu'il n'y avait pas
d'intérêt à ouvrir de nouvelles
interconnexions énergétiques entre
l'Espagne et la France visant notamment
le projet mid4
à gazoduc souterrain dont
l'aboutissement était prochain
semble-t-il et le 20 octobre je Macron
annonce à la presse la mise en place
d'un corridor des énergies vertes le
Barma
Barcelone Marseille visant à créer un
gazon luxe sous-marin devrait être
opérationnel au mieux d'ici 7 ans
notre question est donc celle-ci je peux
y aller ce projet permettra-t-il d'ici 7
ans de pouvoir disposer d'une énergie
moins coûteuse en raison de
l'accroissement des capacités
d'approvisionnement en gaz sur un marché
tendu et la baisse des coût de transport
et quelle sera la stratégie de totale
sur l'hydrogène vers pour exploiter de
façon optimale ces nouvelles
infrastructures merci pour vos réponses
et puis simplement si vous permettez
monsieur le Président d'une
considération tout à fait personnelle je
suis extrêmement surpris de voir un
certain nombre de collègues semblaient
regretter que au total ne soit pas une
entreprise en faillite merci
je vous rassure totale est totalement
désendetté à la fin de l'année et je
pense que c'est plutôt bien pour
l'ensemble d'ailleurs de des salariés et
peut-être aussi de la collectivité
nationale d'avoir un leader mondial de
l'énergie au moment où l'énergie est
juste majeure enfin moi je suis très
fier d'être PDG de cette entreprise et
j'aimerais que ce soit partagé
le votre point l'Espagne l'Espagne en
fait pour moi la question je pense qu'il
y a un vrai sujet avec l'Espagne mais
qui est plutôt l'électricité que le gaz
pour être honnête l'Espagne bénéficie
d'un très gros grosse capacité
d'information de gaz naturel et
historiquement elle prend une vie
difficile aussi d'un tuyau qui remonte
de l'Algérie et elle a beaucoup de
centrales à gaz qui sont très peu
utilisés on est nous sommes présents en
Espagne et donc il y a un potentiel de
production d'électricité aujourd'hui et
demain d'énergie renouvelable puisque
c'est un grand pays où le solaire et le
vent peut s'imposer qui est majeur donc
je moi j'ai recommandé d'ailleurs au
pouvoir vite de regarder si on peut pas
accélérer des interconnexions
électriques qui tiraient beaucoup plus
vite qui serait très utile demain pour
pouvoir alimenter en Europe à partir de
l'Espagne en électricité remonter les
électrons donc premier commentaire moi
je suis très je pense qu'il y a un vrai
potentiel électrique concernant le
projet bon je pense que c'est un projet
qui posait des problèmes
environnementaux importants majeur il se
trouve que il y a 25 ans j'ai travaillé
quand j'étais conseiller de leur
Balladur sur les sujets d'écologie
et des Pyrénées et donc déjà c'était un
sujet qui défrayait la chronique donc je
pense que le projet sous-marin qui
consiste à imaginer faire un gazoduc à
destination hydrogène vert parce qu'en
fait tout ça n'a de sens que si on pense
le futur qui serait sous-marin pour
aller de Barcelone à Marseille et sans
doute beaucoup plus facile à réaliser
d'un point de vue alors j'ai pas regardé
la biodiversité marine de la médaille
mais je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
facile à réaliser que vous leur avez
traversé les Pyrénées qui est
extrêmement compliqué et que ça fait du
sens effectivement la perspective
hydrogène vers l'hydrogène vert est un
sujet sur lequel bien sûr quand vous
êtes un grand producteur d'énergie
global vous y réfléchissez parce que ça
fait partie des molécules qui demain
pourraient devenir pour être venir très
intéressantes la question c'est où
est-ce qu'on le produira la façon le
plus le coup le moins cher possible
c'est ça l'hydrogène vert c'est
l'électricité donc nous sommes en train
de chercher nous sommes en train de
prendre des positions dans des pays pour
pouvoir demain produire de l'hydrogène
vert on prend des positions en ce moment
au Chili on prend des positions en
Mauritanie on prend des positions dans
certains pays
peut être un des pays où on peut
combiner sur les raisons voilà c'est
comme ça qu'il faut comprendre moi je
trouve que le l'accord qui est paru qui
est apparu là récemment au niveau des
États me paraît un bon accord qui
réconcilie les après
et notamment dans cette perspective en
gros une fois hydrogène futur donc le
fait qu'il est en fasse 7 ans pour le
construire n'est pas très grave je pense
qu'à cette horizon là on aura on aura
d'autres façons d'alimenter priorité
devrait être encore une fois les
interconnexions électriques je considère
vis-à-vis de l'Espagne
merci merci beaucoup alors pour les du
côté vert monsieur Julien n'est pas là
madame pochon allez-y
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur vous êtes à la tête de Total
énergie une des 100 entreprises qui ont
émis plus de 71% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre mondial depuis 1988 il
est donc normal que la représentation
nationale vous auditionne et que nous
ayons le droit aussi au respect dans
cette dans cette audition alors même que
nous savons et nous n'avons pas besoin
de bible pour cela Monsieur pouyanet que
la sortie des énergies fossiles et la
condition même de la préservation de
l'habitabilité de la terre et des droits
humains qui sont associés puisque le
droit de vivre dans un environnement
sain a été reconnu par le Conseil d'État
posé dans les paroles sans que sans que
cela soit suivi d'acte une ambition
écologique pourrait être considérée
comme illégal voire criminel peut-être
dans quelques années car oui nous
parlons de droit au droit à pollués et
détruire le monde les droits
fondamentaux de celles et ceux qui
subissent déjà les impacts de vos
activités j'aimerais à cet effet vous
entendre sur le site pétrolier de Total
à balaf au Yémen qui a été réquisitionné
et utilisée depuis plusieurs années par
l'armée des Émirats arabes unis et
transformé en prison secrète ou se
pratiquent créer la torture ainsi que
des violations répétées des droits
humains nous parlons ici de droit et
notamment de potentiels pratiques de
greenwashing quand votre compagnie
réalise toujours près de 90% de ses
investissements dans les énergies
fossiles alors même que l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie ça a déjà
été dit demande à cesser toute nouvelle
exploration possible pour atteindre la
neutralité carbone pour 2050 difficile
de poser une seule question dans vos
activités conditionnent notre avenir
mais puisque vous n'y avez pas encore
répondu Monsieur le Directeur j'aimerais
vous demander si vous pouviez apporter
des clarifications sur votre bilan
global réel des missions de CO2 qui
selon des associations seraient
sous-évaluées au regard de celui de vos
voisins en incluant tous les scopes je
vous remercie
essentiellement par un communiqué nous
allons attaquer d'ailleurs l'association
qui a publié les chiffres faux ce qui
pour une société cotée est un vrai
problème les émissions de scopant Total
sont de 55 millions de tonnes
patrimoniales et 40 millions de tonnes
opérées je vous la firme c'est auditée
régulièrement et ne sont pas de 160
millions de tonnes nous ne représentons
pas 8 % de l'énergie fossile mondiale
mais 1 à 2%. donc un milliards
600 millions de tonnes d'émissions comme
ce rapport les noces c'est 8% des
émissions mondiales ma société ne
représente pas 8% des énergies fossiles
1 à 2% voilà ma réponse est ferme
éclaire et nous irons devant les
tribunaux parce que maintenant ça suffit
d'affirmer des choses et de mentir ce
sont des mensonges qui atteignent à
notre réputation et qui sont graves
quand une société est cotée voilà pour
la deuxième question et je suis
extrêmement ferme et dorénavant toute
affirmation qui sera fausse nous
prendrons nous lui répondrons et nous
attaquerons parce que nous ne pouvons
pas continuer au motif que quelqu'un
lance une information sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'elle devienne une vérité en
l'occurrence je confirme les de scopin
Total énergie sont de 40 millions de
tonnes opérées 45 45 millions de tonnes
opérées et 55 millions de tonnes
patrimoniales et pas de 160 millions de
tonnes ni nous ne représentons pas 8% de
l'énergie mondiale possible non c'est
pas vrai c'est un et demi à deux pour
cent sur votre problème sur Yamal je
réponds
sur yamahal je réponds sur yamahal bon
d'abord non pardon soyez Yémen
Stany mais excusez-moi bon premièrement
c'est pas total l'énergie qui opère le
site de balaf c'est une société qui
s'appelle yaménager nous sommes
actionnaires deuxièmement vous le savez
nous avons dû évacuer ce site et nous
n'avons plus aucun personnel expatrié au
Yémen depuis 2015 en 2017 nous avons
reçu de la part du gouvernement légitime
yéménite une demande de réquisition des
installations pas des installations
industrielles bien évidemment mais des
installations
ou des camps de vie en fait des camps de
vie il se trouve que les candides Yémen
LNG sont séparés les installations
industrielles que nous n'avions pas
moyen de ni opposer à cette réquisition
qui était arrivé au piano nous avons
bien évidemment eu des échanges pour
demander pourquoi et nous avons demandé
que il soit bien séparé qu'il y a une
enceinte qui a été créée pour que
séparer correctement les installations
industrielles de ce fameux camp de vie
nous ne savons absolument pas nous
n'avons personne nous ne savons
absolument pas ce qui se passe et je
comme nous l'avons dit vous le répétons
nous savons absolument pas ce qui se
passe dans les installations
réquisitionnées puisque nous ne sommes
pas retournés au Yémen depuis 2015 le
Yémen pour nous puisque cette usine
représentait à peu près 30 à 40 % des
revenus de l'État nous considérons nous
avons un devoir d'essayer de la
maintenir en état elle existe toujours
malgré les malgré la guerre civile
depuis maintenant 8 ans nous coûte de
l'argent comme nous avec nos cours
actionnaires mais je ne dispose aucune
d'information spécifique et bien
évidemment après que nous ayons été
saisis et que ces accusations étaient
prononcées nous avons saisi des
autorités du Yémen nous avons fait notre
devoir qui bien évidemment nous ont
répondu qu'il n'y avait pas de qu'il n'y
avait rien mais je n'ai pas de moyens
d'investigation et nous ne sommes en
aucune façon partie à ce qui se passe
dans la partie qui a été réquisitionné
par un état un état légitime enfin un
état qui a révisionné les installations
encore une fois la partie de l'usine et
je peux vous dire ce qui s'y passe
puisqu'on a encore des gens qui vont
personnel de yémenage
et simplement pour quelle raison parce
qu'on il y a un tout petit peu de gaz
qui permet d'alimenter en électricité
les villages environnement voilà voilà
ce que je peux vous dire sur le Yémen la
situation est claire et puisque là aussi
on veut nous attaquer nous répondrons et
je peux vous dire que c'est un sujet sur
lequel nous voyons tout particulièrement
à ce que tout ce qui puisse être fait
par l'entreprise mais encore une fois
nous n'avons pas de moyens d'agir soit
conforme à l'ensemble de nos règles et
nos actes de conduite voilà je vous
remercie madame Saint-Paul
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur
quelque chose comme trois je vous ai dit
8% 8% c'est pas ne faisons pas j'ai
répondu 8% c'est pas 2%
allez-y madame allez-y vas-y Monsieur le
Directeur j'ai l'habitude de dire que
c'est le terrain qui commande et je
voulais saluer localement l'action de
Arnaud patio qui a fait l'effort de
venir à notre rencontre pour pour
accompagner nos projets et pour
présenter justement
l'entreprise puisque total se sont
beaucoup d'employés et j'ai coutume de
dire qu'à la campagne en roulant encore
beaucoup au diesel donc dans des plaies
à certains et je voulais savoir
finalement aujourd'hui dans quelle
mesure la France a encore le centre de
gravité de votre entreprise en termes
d'actionnaires en termes d'emploi
puisque vous êtes une multinationale
au sein de 130 pays mais voilà c'est
important moi je conseille encore total
comme une fierté nationale dans des
plaisants corps à certains donc voilà
savoir dans quelle mesure c'est encore
une entreprise française avec son centre
de gravité en France
et vous avez eu beaucoup d'accusations
de greenwashing j'y vois un paradoxe par
rapport au RSE qui vous incombent donc
moi j'ai beaucoup de projets à
accompagner donc il y a un moment on
peut pas imposer un RSE porter nous
localement des projets et être accusé
systématiquement de greenwashing donc je
voudrais votre réponse sur ces questions
je vous remercie madame la France c'est
3530.000 entre 30 32000 employés sur 100
000 donc c'est beaucoup d'employés tous
nos seront en recherche sont ici le
système de raffinage etc nos réseaux
plus gros réseau mondial est en France
notre réseau la France
ça représente des investissements
significatifs chaque année on investit
par exemple dans l'électricité c'est sur
la France qu'on a fait un pari important
en reprenant Direct Énergie donc notre
diversification notre stratégie passe
par la France la France et notre siège
la France est et c'est important pour
nous d'ailleurs
les dirigeantes total énergie sont
encore à majorité française en termes
d'actionnariat c'est à peu près 18%
l'actionnariat qui diminue c'est dommage
l'actionnariat qui monte au capital de
l'énergie sélectionnant américain au fur
et à mesure des années cette année on a
à peu près 5% de plus d'actionnaires
américains
ce que je constate donc on voilà donc là
oui la France je totale a une
nationalité qui est française j'ai aucun
doute et c'est pour ça que nous nous
préoccupons
de
ce qu'on peut faire ici en France
lorsqu'on met en place des systèmes de
rabais commerciaux sur la France ou des
opérations de bonus sur l'électricité
comme on l'a annoncé hier on le fait en
France on le fait pas dans tous les pays
du monde donc on a un lien particulier
avec avec le pays voilà et donc s'il y a
des projets
territoriaux bien sûr on est prêt à les
accompagner dans les divers
ce que je peux vous dire nous avons
d'ailleurs mis en place depuis un an une
organisation qu'on n'avait pas vous
l'avez j'ai un jour je me suis rendu
compte que finalement on traitait la
France était bizarre parce que la France
est d'ailleurs chez moi qui viens ici
vous voyez PDG va s'occuper de la France
il se trouve qu'il est aussi PDG d'un
groupe mondial on n'avait pas de patron
de France on a désigné quelqu'un en
charge de la France et on vient de
mettre en place une organisation
territoriale avec un délégué régional
dans chacune des régions de façon à
pouvoir retisser du lien avec l'ensemble
des élus et notamment parce que les
énergies renouvelables nous ramènent
vraiment plus on veut les développer sur
le terrain et donc si on veut arriver à
notre ambition sur ce terrain là il faut
qu'on soit beaucoup plus présent près du
pays voilà ce que je peux donc voilà
comment on réaborde le territoire le
territoire français
bien je vous remercie alors je vais on
va terminer on a j'ai encore trois
demandes de parole on va mettre donc une
du rassemblement national monsieur
buisson et puis j'ai deux de LFI qui
sont madame auziol et madame à vos
Mongolie donc je propose que on groupe
les questions même si elles seront très
distinctes j'en suis bien conscient et
que et que non vous n'êtes pas inscrite
et que et que le président puyanais
répondent monsieur buisson je suis
désolé Mireille je n'ai en raison de la
guerre en Ukraine nous apportons du
génie américain au prix fort vous en
avez parlé les prix de l'énergie ont
grimpé la France est menacée de
destruction de son industrie qui
pourrait être attirée à terme aux
États-Unis c'est une aubaine à double
titre pour notre allié américain nous
devons sécuriser un approvisionnement
énergétique a pris raisonnable pour nos
compatriotes et pour la survie nos
entreprises donc monsieur pouyanet
pensez-vous que les importations de gaz
provenant du gisement Léviathan pour une
solution pour compenser le découplage
gazier russe européen votre entreprise a
été critiquée en 2019 par le ministre
israélien de l'énergie quand vous allez
déclaré que la situation en Israël ce
nouvel acteur gazier était trop complexe
pour investir dans ce gisement donc
monsieur le ministre a même évoqué
pardon un boycot d'Israël par Total qui
ferait partie toujours selon ce ministre
de des entreprises soumises à la
tyrannie et la dictature en Iran
toutefois total c'était désengagé l'Iran
2018 du fait des sanctions américaines
encore une fois à cause des sanctions
américaines dont ma seconde question
monsieur pouyanet et dernière dans la
dans quelle mesure les activités totales
comme de nombreuses entreprises
françaises par ailleurs ont été freinées
voire empêchées par des considérations
politiques ou disons-le par la politique
extérieure américaine
merci merci Madame audiol et après
monsieur Ruffin en chacun
et après c'est Monsieur pouillané de
partir à 45 on ne peut pas je sais pas
ce qui s'est passé Mireille on verra ça
oui monsieur le Président bon c'est un
peu étrange de devoir raccourcir sa
question comme ça l'intérêt de ce type
d'audition c'est de pouvoir échanger et
avoir de vraies réponses
oui mais bon hier soir par exemple on
aurait bien aimé que on puisse
s'exprimer aussi longuement donc bah je
vais raccourcir c'est sur les activités
de Total aux Mozambique que porte ma
question sur le site dafongi pour être
plus précise le journaliste marque un
Develde dont nous saluons le travail
rapporte que le groupe Total a fait
appel au groupe paramilitaire russe
Wagner pour protéger ses installations
au Mozambique jusqu'au retrait de Total
en 2021 à l'époque déjà nous
connaissions les liens entre cette
société militaire privée et le
renseignement militaire russe du GRU et
également les liens avec le FSB et ma
question est la suivante la DGSE et
l'Élysée était-il au courant ont-ils
donné le feu vert à total pour
travailler avec ce groupe paramilitaire
nous n'avons jamais travaillé bien
évidemment avec le groupe Wagner nous
n'employons aucune société privée
militaire la réponse est très claire et
simple encore une affirmation fausse
votre épouse se tenait très bien dans
les charges monsieur Ruffin j'ai répondu
madame monsieur Ruffin
si vous
pouvez répondre monsieur le Président
Monsieur Ruffin voulait dire quelque
chose Monsieur le Président total a
pratiqué pendant des décennies
l'industrie du doute en matière
climatique en étant dans le déni en
finançant des revues alors je vous vois
froncer les sourcils donc je peux vous
vous aligner des citations entières de
revues de Total qui interroge sur la
réalité du réchauffement climatique et
sur le fait que est-ce que ça serait
d'origine humaine quel serait la place
là-dedans vous avez fait ça pendant
décennies jusque début des années 2000
vous avez opéré un revirement du déni
vers le greenwashing mais ce que
j'entends moi aujourd'hui quand on vous
parle des activités total en Ouganda par
exemple c'est la même industrie du doute
c'est à dire que quand vous contestez
les chiffres mais au fond les chiffres
que vous donnez en disant c'est 18000
foyers 18000 foyers ça fait bien cent
mille personnes ça fait 100000 personnes
quand on lit les récits qui sont opérés
de gens qui me font sur place ce sont
des filatures ce sont des arrestations
c'est de la prison c'est des managers
sur les populations qui sont musées non
pas par vous directement évidemment mais
vous faites faire le sale boulot par les
sous-traitants
tout à l'heure je vous entends vous
offusquez sur le fait que il y a un état
de droit comment ça se fait que le
Parlement européen il vous a pas entendu
dans le cas d'un étang de droit et je
veux bien entendre vos droits et entendu
par le Parlement européen mais ce qui se
passe pour un certain nombre de
populations là-bas l'État de droit ils
n'existe pas
moi ce que je souhaiterais c'est que il
y a la possibilité d'avoir une véritable
mission
parlementaire qui se rendent sur le site
de Total en Ouganda et qui permet puisse
permettre d'interroger librement ce qui
n'a pas été possible pour le Parlement
européen qui permette d'interroger
librement les populations sur vous merci
Monsieur Ruffin monsieur monsieur
pouyanet alors d'abord le point sur
Israël Iran ont d'abord sachez que nous
venons de contribuer à avec
un accord entre le Liban Israël sur la
frontière maritime au bénéfice qui
permet de libérer des ressources côté
libanais gazières et que nos relations
avec l'État d'Israël sont très bonnes
premièrement puisque nous avons
nous-mêmes
rentrer les États-Unis ont piloté avec
la France à négociation au niveau
diplomatique mais nous avons un rôle
puisque on avait signé un accord
d'ailleurs cette semaine pour faire en
sorte que cet accord puisse se mettre en
oeuvre positivement premièrement nous
sommes d'ailleurs investisseurs en
Israël nous avons des idées de batterie
de ce qu'on a racheté soft et on y
investit dans le solaire également
deuxièmement
est-ce que on a eu un souci vous le
savez lorsque les extensions
extraterritale américaine s'appliquent
nous avons nous avons renoncé au projet
en Iran oui parce que les sanctions
américaines s'appliquaient et que
l'Europe ne pouvait pas ne pouvait pas
n'avait pas les moyens d'empêcher de s'y
opposer en 1995 les procédants au projet
iraniens l'Europe c'était opposé en 2017
18 l'Europe ne s'y est pas opposée donc
nous avons renoncé au projet iranien
c'est le seul cas que je connais il faut
savoir qu'il y a aujourd'hui 82 pays
sous sanction extraterritoriale
américaine 82 pays
il y en avait 10 il y a 10 ans donc
c'est une c'est effectivement au sujet
aujourd'hui pour des sociétés
internationales qui devronter
toutes ces règles parce qu'on est aussi
des intérêts aux États-Unis un sujet de
contraintes mais c'est la réalité de
notre monde
voilà vous m'avez posé une question j'ai
revendu en Israël États-Unis j'ai
répondu je pense sur Wagner
je vais répondre à Monsieur à Monsieur
Ruffin
pardon
j'ai pas entendu
sur monsieur Ruffin
d'abord je voudrais revenir sur un point
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure que j'ai
pas répondu je me suis rendu compte
puisqu'on me dit vous avez affirmé que
si vous partiez quelqu'un d'autre sur le
projet il se trouve que oui je suis pas
seul sur le projet ou garder j'ai un
partenaire qui est à peu près le même
pourcentage que nous qui s'appelle sinoo
c'est une société d'État chinoise et il
faut savoir sur ce projet pendant deux
ans nous sommes battus pour en garder le
contrôle parce que les sociétés en Sinou
voulait devenir l'opérateur à notre
place donc je peux partir et en vous
écoutant c'est ce que je dois faire mais
le projet il va avoir lieu
il va avoir lieu parce que l'Ouganda
veut le projet parce que la Tanzanie
veut le projet l'Ouganda la tanzani sont
et 159e et 160e pays les plus pauvres
est-ce que nous sommes prêts aujourd'hui
à leur dire vous laissez vos ressources
dans la terre et nous vous apportons des
milliards est-ce qu'on est est-ce que
est-ce que nous avons fait cette
proposition ou est-ce qu'on se contente
de faire parce que j'ai été accusé tout
à l'heure de de colonialisme
néo-colonialisme nous comporter
exactement de cette façon là en disant
non nous jugeons que vous n'avez pas le
droit de produire ces ressources
naturelles
c'est un vrai sujet moi j'ai pas entendu
la proposition venant des autorités
européennes allez dire aux autorités
ougandaises et tanzaniennes laisser ce
pétrole et nous allons vous compenser
pour la totalité des revenus vous
pourriez en tirer je l'ai pas entendu
d'ailleurs par ailleurs nous-mêmes nous
avons décidé qu'une partie importante
des revenus plus pourrions tirer nous le
réinvestirions dans l'énergie
renouvelable de ces pays-là pour pouvoir
déployer notre propre modèle dans les
pays où nous extrayons des ressources
pour le bénéfice de ces populations de
ces populations et des pccpi donc voilà
après vous me dites il y a des policiers
bon écoutez on va pas rentrer je vous
signale que d'ailleurs au passage je
vais quand même dire la vérité ce qui
s'est passé
façon de Parlement européens nous ont
demandé de pouvoir aller en Ouganda et
nous les avons idée à y aller ils se
sont promenés totalement librement au
mois de juillet août totalement
librement
en Ouganda
ils l'ont déjà fait
voilà donc moi j'ai pas de problème on a
ouvert les portes du projet en Ouganda
le son de guerre de pas mal de
journalistes ils sont allés je l'avais
proposé au mois de mai mais si vous
voulez y aller allez-y et vous me direz
si vous voyez 100000 personnes menottées
et menacées
parce que si c'est vrai je suis prêt à
arrêter c'est pas vrai voilà ce que je
peux vous dire sur ce dossier en Ouganda
que nous assumons qui est pas un sujet
simple je vous ai donné des chiffres
nous ferons tout ce que nous devons
faire au mieux dans l'intérêt de ces
populations ne vont pas du tout envie
c'est pas notre comportement c'est un
sujet complexe et des sujets à terre qui
sont terrestres oui qui sont plus
compliqués mais on va on va tomber sur
les mêmes problématiques lorsqu'on va
vouloir construire des centrales
solaires
exactement les mêmes problèmes les
centrales solaires c'est à sol
et on va voir exactement et on commence
à avoir dans tous les pays ce problème
d'occupation de l'espace
donc voilà ce que je pense sur ce
dossier ougandé encore une fois
peut-être que vous allez réussir à me
convaincre non c'est je vais vendre mes
parts je vais vendre mes parts à la
société d'État chinoise
oui parce que le projet il est parti
non non non non parce que non parce
qu'ils ont à droite de préemption nos
amis chinois vous savez donc c'est ah
bah oui quand on a déjà des sociétés
conjointe en général mais je les ai
aussi vis-à-vis d'eux s'ils s'en vont
voilà donc voilà ce que je peux vous
dire sur ce dossier c'est pas un dossier
très simple c'est je regrette
profondément qu'on en arrive aujourd'hui
à ces affrontements parce qu'en fait
profondément je crois à la bonne volonté
de nos équipes sur le terrain qui font
ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut pour faire en sorte de il
y a eu beaucoup d'ailleurs au passage
sur ce dossier nous avons invité un
centre de ONG qui ont fourni des
rapports d'audit que nous avons rendu
public par rapport à chacune des
recommandations qui nous ont été faites
nous avons répondu nous les avons mis en
œuvre de façon à nous améliorer je dis
pas qu'on est parfait j'ai simplement
que ce dossier alors après il y a deux
débats là-dedans il y a un débat
que je comprends qui est faut-il
produire de nouveaux gisements
pétroliers je vous ai expliqué pourquoi
dans les prochaines années il faut le
faire justement où blander il sera
épuisé dans 15 ans on sera pas en 2050
voilà mais j'expliquais pourquoi oui
nous pensons qu'il faut continuer à
produire tout le temps continuant à
investir plus dans les énergies des
carbonées parce qu'il faut assurer
l'énergie de d'aujourd'hui parce que par
ailleurs total énergie a un contrat avec
ses états là
et que dans notre entreprise oui nous
restons les contrats que nous passons
avec tous les États qui nous font
confiance voilà
monsieur le Président il y a madame
clapot qui a été oublié
j'apprécie monsieur le Président je
m'intéresse particulièrement à la loi
sur le devoir de vigilance qui date de
2017 qui va faire sans doute écho après
au niveau européen et donc votre groupe
il est particulièrement scruté on a
entendu la virulence des collègues qui
vous ont interpellé mais il y a aussi
au-delà de l'invocation de la morale et
des affirmations des autres il y a la
justice et donc vous étiez le 12 octobre
devant le tribunal c'est reporter ou 7
décembre il y a tout un feuilleton
autour de ça est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire ce que vous en pensez et si pour
vous c'est vraiment une contrainte ou si
ça peut être une opportunité et puis je
voulais aussi mentionner le reportage
d'hier soir je n'ai pas pu voir
malheureusement sur Arte mais qui était
très à charge merci
si vous me trouvez un papier ou un
documentaire pas à charge en ce moment
je ne vois pas beaucoup
on a quelques-uns de temps en temps qui
qui font bizarrement plaisir alors qu'on
s'y attend pas
ce qui est dommage c'est très frustrant
surtout que le plus frustrant je vais
vous dire dans la position que j'ai
c'est que ça se passe dans notre pays
dont nous sommes le plus proche et le
plus fier
nous sommes pas attaqués dans les autres
pays du monde dans les 129 autres pays
où nous sommes implantés
pas du tout on est même considéré
aujourd'hui dans beaucoup de pays comme
l'entreprise pétrolière la plus
avant-gardiste dans son changement de
modèle développement et c'est le pays
où nous avons notre siège nous avons nos
employés qui nous attaque le plus bon
c'est un peu frustrant mais mais mes
collègues mes collègues britanniques
subissent le même effet mes collègues
américains également bon voilà donc nul
les prophètes en sont pays
pour revenir sur votre question le voir
vigilance écoutez on va voir ce que nous
nous comprenons ce texte
comme la volonté du Parlement d'éviter
les situations qu'il y avait eu
notamment dans des sous-traitants en
Inde il y a eu un drame etc bon on
commence à en voir l'obligation que nous
avons fixé le Parlement par la loi c'est
une obligation de m'avoir un plan
obligation d'avoir une phase d'assurance
qualité qui nous permet de nous assurer
à travers des de faire un rapport annuel
d'avoir des processus et des assurances
l'obligation de processus pour vous
assurer que on met en oeuvre et qu'on
vérifie que un centre de valeurs
fondamentale sont bien respectées dans
les projets pour résumer un petit peu
on verra ce que les tribunaux
comprennent puisque une des demandes
c'est qu'on nous dit vous n'avez pas
décrit chacun des projets dans votre
rapport si je dois décrire chacun des
projets dans le rapport le rapport qui
est déjà épais il va il va grossir
beaucoup donc effectivement on a une
méthode pour respecter de l'avoir
vigilance on a fait un plan et qui est
très conforme on l'a comparé aux autres
grandes sociétés françaises qui ont émis
des plans on n'a pas considéré que le
nôtre était de moins bonne qualité donc
la difficulté auquel on fait face sur le
plan judiciaire c'est une interprétation
de ce texte qui va qui en gros c'est non
pas qu'il ne regarde pas ce qui est
écrit dans l'article de loi la lettre de
la loi mais qui dit non mais vous devez
être vigilant tout le temps enfin une
espèce de qui va au-delà de l'obligation
légale on va voir ce que les tribunaux
comment les tribunaux vont juger il y
avait une demande une demande de
médiation possible avec les ONG on était
prêt à le faire ce gênant pas souhaité
donc on verra ce que le tribunal de
première instance dira il y aura à mon
avis on est parti pour une insécurité
juridique assez ma sur ce texte le
niveau européen effectivement reprend le
concept on verra comment tout ça sera
rendu compatible moi ce qui m'ennit en
termes de je lis en termes de
compétition internationale c'est que ce
genre de texte n'a aucune chance
d'apparaître à côté américain
et ça c'est un vrai problème
il faut vous rendre compte quand même
j'en profite que les sociétés
européennes aujourd'hui pensent de
réglementation qui s'en sort de toutes
légitime mais qui ne s'appliquent pas à
l'ensemble d'un autre à nos vrais
compétiteur et nos vrais compétiteur
aujourd'hui ils sont largement américain
m'a fait que les sociétés européennes
doivent se battre dans la compétition
mondiale avec plus de contraintes que
nos compétiteurs je ne dis pas que c'est
pas bien je dis simplement que ce qui
serait bien c'est ce que lorsque nous
Européens on veut progresser dans les
normes sociales environnementales ou
comme celle que porte ce genre de texte
et encore une fois je j'en comprends la
l'idée mais qu'elle s'applique au moins
dans le champ des alliés de champ
transatlantique parce que c'est ça notre
compétition aujourd'hui elle
s'appliqueront encore moins bien
évidemment en Chine mais ça j'ai même
pas l'illusion de le vouloir mais ce qui
m'ennuie beaucoup aujourd'hui c'est que
quand je vois l'évolution de l'autre
côté de l'Atlantique on en est pas là
voilà bon après encore une fois c'est
pas un texte très simple parce que
encore une fois il y a la lettre de ce
qui est écrit dans la loi et puis il y a
l'intention que certains veulent que
visiblement de certaines parties
prenantes veulent lui donner et ça ça
devient complexe on verra ce qui se
passera mais encore une fois nous sommes
dans un état droit et nous respectons
l'état droit donc à la fin la justice
aura raison
je pense que le feuilleton judiciaire de
cette affaire n'est pas fini
merci merci monsieur le Président je
crois que c'est un
vraiment je remercie de la précision de
de la franchise
et du caractère extrêmement riche de vos
réponses je pense que vraiment je
remercie les collègues d'avoir posé
toutes les questions qu'ils ont posé
vraiment c'est une audition dans lequel
grâce à vous nous n'avons pas perdu
notre temps or nous sommes nous sommes
bien pays placés au parlement national
pour savoir que c'est très facile d'y
perdre son temps et et là je pense que
nous avons vraiment fait progresser
notre conscience des enjeux chacun a ses
positions à à ses responsabilités voit
les choses comme il l'entend mais je
pense que vous avez très très
sérieusement enrichi notre niveau de
conscience de l'ensemble de ces
problèmes soyez-en remercier j'espère
que vous avez considéré que les
questions parfois les mises en cause
parfois un peu brutale de nos collègues
étaient évidemment uniquement dictée par
le souci de faire progresser le débat et
la vérité vous n'en doutez pas un seul
instant moi non plus je n'en doute
aucunement enfin c'est l'intérêt des
débats c'est d'entendre les divers
points de vue qui s'expriment et les
dirigeants que je suis se nourrit aussi
de ce genre de débat pour faire évoluer
notre nos propres réflexions c'est un
débat très riche et je vous remercie de
vous y êtes prêté merci à vous pour
votre accueil la séance élevé